good evening it's nine o'clock an hour
to go until the polls closed an hour to
go until we reveal the findings of the
exit poll an hour to go in the brexit
election
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening it's six weeks now since
Parliament voted to trigger the brexit
election on now there's less than an
hour to run tonight who govern Britain
for the next five years should become
clear and hear from the heart of sky
we'll bring you every result to guide us
our political editor Beth Rigby I'm the
man who's come to define politics in
modern Britain as a common speaker for
the last decade John Bercow more from
him
in a moment well it could be a long
night tonight and here in our sky
election center we'll be using all the
tools at our disposal to predict its
course that begins in just 58 minutes
time with the release of the
broadcaster's exit poll so often
questioned by politicians put very
rarely wrong it's the moment you learn
the likely path of this election first
though very special guest
[Applause]
naturally a choir man your strong views
on a lot of things so he likes debating
quite frankly young man you can like it
or lump it it's in it with absolute
commitment ruthless efficiency and along
the way there's been some collateral
damage you really are a very very very
generous bunch of people indeed
[Music]
well John Bercow welcome to Sky News how
are you feeling excited and privileged
privileged to be on the Sky News team
for election night the best most focused
without question quickest sharpest
political news team to be found anywhere
in the UK you are very kind the exit
poll the first big events of the evening
it very very important pointer as to how
things might go yes of course it's
important to understand what the exit
poll is it's not just like any other
poll other polls asked people how they
are going to vote the exit poll of
course asks people when they come out of
the polling stations how they have voted
and although politicians didn't always
like to hear the exit poll the exit poll
on four out of the last five occasions
has been accurate in its basic thrust in
predicting either a hung parliament or a
majority government pretty good points
here okay that comes up at ten also with
me throughout the night our political
editor beth rigby now she of course is
tracking parties and their leaders
throughout this grueling general
election campaign better well that comes
to a conclusion tonight in the studio
I've done a few thousand miles I think
what an extraordinary period of British
politics this isn't and here we are in
the December election the first in
nearly a century but it is as everyone
know our third general election in
nearly under five years and the two
contenders this week they were up and
down the country a dizzying tour as
they're trying to pick up votes Jeremy
Corbyn 15 pit stops in three days from
Glasgow right down to Bristol and Boris
Johnson 11 stops concentrating his
efforts in the Midlands and the north in
places like great GLIP Grimsby fighting
for every vote right up until the polls
close in this awful weather but they'll
still be trying to turn out the vote I'm
counting down to that polls closing in
the exit poll 56 minutes or so well
elections can be difficult to follow of
course but you'll be able to get all the
key data right here there it is at the
bottom of this screen this is our
election vide printer it's going to tell
you the result of that exit poll we've
been talk
about after it's released ten o'clock
and the latest seats to declare them
coming after that it then keeps a
running tally of the number of MPs that
each and every one of those parties have
won well also here at Sky News we've
always believed that the election nights
story is told as much outside the studio
as here on tonight my colleagues will be
right across the country starting with
the party leaders first to be
conservative and labor camps and Donna
botting and Sophie Ridge Anna any nerves
there indeed so always nerves not least
the counters Dermot 12 candidates
standing here in the seat of Oxbridge
and South France lip as you said the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson is the
incumbent taking the seat first in 2015
and then winning again here in 2017 we
are at the extremities of West London if
I can put it like that a constituency
dominated in part by neighbouring
Heathrow Airport Brunel University is
here too which is where this count and
that of two others will take place
tonight including that of the Shadow
Chancellor John McDonnell expecting all
the candidates to arrive later the Prime
Minister included so where is he now
let's take you to Downing Street and our
political correspondent Kate McCann who
has been following the TOI leader for
the past five weeks and Kate the Prime
Minister's standing by tonight there in
Downing Street that's right Anna Boris
Johnson is here in Downing Street behind
me where he will be nervously awaiting
that exit poll at 10 o'clock as the rest
of us are it's been a long campaign for
all the candidates the Prime Minister
has travelled over 10,000 miles in this
general election campaign covered every
region of the country and now it all
comes down to what happens next he will
be with advisers in Downing Street
talking about some of the very many ways
that this election could go next and
what might happen next he's having
something to eat and drink trying to get
ready for the long night ahead before he
will head to Oxbridge where the votes
will be counted where you are Anna and
where I will be later we saw the Prime
Minister casting his ballot this morning
in Westminster he took his dog Dillon
along with him for that so a long night
ahead the Prime Minister will head from
here to ox bridge where he will see out
that can't
depending on what happens next he could
be returning to Downing Street or it
could well have another incumbent Kate
McCann thank you very much indeed well
the declaration for John McDonald's
constituency is due at about 4:00 a.m.
that of Oxbridge where the Prime
Minister is standing due at about 4:30
in the morning well what about the
Labour leader let's get the very latest
now from Sophie which thank you Anna
well welcome to the sobel leisure centre
in Islington North constituency of a1
Jeremy Corbyn this particular area of
North London is home to to our
constituencies there'll be two counts
going on tonight jeremy corbyn's count
and isn't a north and there'll also be
talking up the votes in Islington south
and Finsbury which is the constituency
of the shadow foreign secretary
Emily Thornbury to give you a bit of a
steer on how long we could have to wait
to get those results there isn't in
South and Finsbury seat normally
declares first last year it was around
1:00 in the morning being easing to
North constituency a little bit later
was about 3:00 a.m. last time that we
heard the results of her jeremy corbyn's
seat and that's when you're going to be
getting the acting returning officer
taken to the stage that I hope we should
go to see just behind me to have her
moment in the spotlight announcing that
results that's the chief executive of
the council as well but it's a huge
operation on the ground as these seats
always are they've had 650 people out
about in polling stations across her
Islington as people cast their ballots
one person who cast his vote a little
bit earlier today was the Labour leader
himself and the sky's home editor Jason
Farrell has been following the Labour
campaign and is now outside jeremy
corbyn's at home tonight Jason you know
as you think yes I think or they didn't
look tuner too nervous oh I saw them
just a moment ago I'll talk about that
in a minute he he's obviously had this
500 mile trek yesterday from Glasgow to
London but it didn't take his foot off
the gas this morning he was out casting
his vote as you say at 9:30
I was with his wife Laura then he was
out campaigning he stopped off for a few
cups of coffee then it was back here I
didn't think I'd have much to tell you
but actually I can tell you he has gone
out for dinner tonight when I was here
just about 20 minutes ago he came out of
the house again with one of his advisers
wife Laura
I told he was going off for dinner and
he said that they weren't sure whether
he was going to come back here at all
actually he did tell me that he thought
the count in Islington when I was on the
campaign with him would come back at
about 2:00 a.m. but as you say
previously it's come back up a little
bit later than that around about 3 a.m.
I think by then he'll have a pretty good
idea of the way things are going when I
was here last time back in 2017 they
were having a sweepstake back here on
what would happen obviously this time
wherever they are there'll be very much
glued to those exit polls and a lot more
up for grabs than who wins the
sweepstake yeah the Labour leaders team
and the rest of us as well Jason thank
you and of course it's when that exit
poll comes in in around 50 minutes time
that the white will really start for the
150 people here in the room they've
already started arriving Lots them they
were on their seats ready to go just as
soon as those ballot boxes start
arriving and will of course bring either
results as soon as we'll get them
doumitt in the meantime back to you in
the studio
okay Sophie thank you very much indeed
thank you Anna very much as well when
we're hearing much more of course from
you both throughout the evening now
tonight here in our sky election centre
we're going to be analyzing the numbers
and the trends which will define this
election that's the last election Sky
News was the first to call that it was
going to be a hung parliament that no
party would have an outright majority
more than an hour ahead of our rivals
that unexpected result that so took the
wind out of tourism a sales well talking
us through the results tonight disguise
ed Conway Edie what is the aim of every
party in an election well of course it's
to get their leader in to number 10
Downing Street winning a majority of
seats in parliament so here's our
winning line from last time around you
see the Conservatives once 300
and 18 seats they fell short of that
line by eight seats and although labor
gained seats they finished with 262 so
we got a hung parliament the toys had to
join forces with the DUP to form a
government this time there'll be hoping
to win back some of the seats they lost
in 2017 so let's see how things looked
after the last election these are the
number of seats won by each party look
at them there they are on our dashboard
there and you can see behind them if we
fly by there or hexagon map of the UK at
the top you can see a lot of SNP yellow
there in Scotland there's also some blue
there the Conservatives gained a dozen
new Scottish MPs in 2017 the rest of the
country is mostly conservative blue and
Labour red you can see labour did well
in the West gaining seats in Wales and
the southwest and you've got some Lib
Dem yellow in London where they also
gained seats but there'll be some big
names missing from tonight's as well
Philip Hammond and amber Rudd two former
cabinet ministers who aren't standing at
this election labour losing deputy
leader Tom Watson and former Sports
Minister Kate Hoey servants cable to the
former Lib Dem leader and Lady Sylvia
Herman who sat as an independent in
Northern Ireland they are among more
than 70 MPs who won't be standing this
time around in all the Commons we'll
lose more than a thousand years of
parliamentary experience well tonight
joining Ed Conway and crunching those
numbers will be our team of safale
gist's experts in the study of elections
and voting trends skies election
analysts for every election since Sky
News was founded indeed professor
Michael Thrasher well he's right now
inside those exit poll deliberations
which we'll be able to bring you the
result of let me remind you 10 o'clock
on the dot but do not fear because our
deputy political editor Sam Coates is
here and joins me now and Sam tell us
more about this exit poll Thank You
Dermot so on the stroke of 10:00 p.m.
the first indication of the nation's
decision with the Sky News BBC an ITV
News exit poll throughout the day if
sauce mori interviewed around 30,000
people coming out of polling stations in
a hundred and forty-four different
locations voters fill in replica ballot
papers
after they cast their vote which is what
makes this exercise different to
conventional polls will someone have won
an outright majority will it be another
hung parliament the exit poll has
captured the shock and the drama before
just two years ago the exit poll was a
surprise to almost everybody so hold
your breath those results in just under
50 minutes time okay Sam thank you very
much indeed well on election night it's
the Battle of course to be first in
Parliament that really counts but at
least for the next two hours we'll also
be focused on another race that's to be
the first constituency to declare in
this general election now for five
elections those keen followers amongst
you will know that in till 2017 that
ground was claimed by Sunderland but
last time around their local right.you
Castle no less pit them to the post
turned out this is the scene right now
in those two great cities as the teams
they're prepared to collect and count
those ballot papers as quickly as
possible all being well we could hear
the first result in less than two hours
time and these are the people who tell
us who's going to win that race Gillian
Joseph and Sarah Jamie Gillian the team
they're in Newcastle dwellers were
saying they they hold the crown and they
confident of hanging on to it absolutely
so Dermot and you get the sense that
there is a rivalry going on here a
healthy one or B say we should say if
it's a healthy rival but there is one
going on you can see already that the
post all votes are coming in behind me
those ballot boxes on the table there so
it's all underway in earnest now are we
taking the account from three
constituencies here this evening from
Newcastle Central East and north and
there's a lot at stake as you said
because Newcastle took the crown in 2017
for being the fastest constituency to
declare they declared at one minute past
eleven and just nine minutes afterwards
Sunderland came in second not a position
that they were happy with because as you
say since 1992 they've held a crown for
being the fastest constituency to
declare so there's a lot to play for
this evening in Newcastle maybe
changed their venue they used to be at
that Civic Hall there in this sports
center because it's larger two reasons
its larger and also because these back
doors mean that vehicles can drive
straight up to the doors and running
with the boxes and that all adds up to
valuable minutes which will be crucial
in the race with Sunderland so who will
reclaim the crown will it be Newcastle
or will it be Sunderland let's take you
over to the rival camp now at Sunderland
with Sarah Jamie
jyllian hello wellcan Sundlun win back
its crown and they are ready welcome to
the Sunderland side of this election
derby over the course of the night here
we're going to be getting the results of
three votes patent and Sunderland
control and Washington and Sunderland
West now back in June 2017 all three
seats here were won by the Labour Party
were the Conservatives in second place
the early attention tonight will be on
Houghton and Sons of himself as Dermot
and Gillian both said it reigned supreme
in terms of declaring first and it was
picked to the post back in 2017 by
Newcastle Central the team here hoping
to recapture that old magic which also
saw them achieve the fastest ever
declaration that came back in 2015 at
10:48 p.m. less than an hour after the
polls closed if that happens I'll be
going home early and watching the rest
their coverage from a hotel now you
might be asking how on earth do they do
all this well over 1,000 people are here
to help out as part of the count team
they're all limbering up behind me you
can hear the noise is getting louder
they also say took a step a few years
ago to make their ballot papers thinner
and that makes it easier to count and of
course much quicker time a lady tell if
all of these preparations help them
regain their title around half an hour
I'm going to speak to the returning
officer for this Sunderland count to get
more on the operation being run here and
how they think it's going to go so we'll
be talking to him a little bit later on
but for now Dermot back to you I'm sure
it's going to be tight Gillian Sarah
Jane thank you both we'll be hearing
much more from you over the next couple
of hours well Matt the trends that
decide this election could prove to be
amongst the most difficult to define of
modern times there are so many dividing
lines now not just the traditional
questions of left and right and so on
and so forth tonight we have a new tool
to explore the election battleground and
their heads up here now to explain it
tell us about it there Ned that's right
so I mean it's election night it's all
about numbers and boy if we've got some
interesting ways of showing you what's
going on beneath the surface you saw
over there in the atrium the big banners
that might tell you the scores let's
have a look at some of the background
stories
every election of course is different
but this election might be decided in an
unexpected way so let's have a look at
the map which shows the UK and how it
voted last time around because that map
is a key way of showing you just what
happened in the last election there you
can see that a hexagram map of the UK
and you can see the seats from last time
around out that geography tells you one
story but there are many ways of dicing
those numbers of looking at what's going
on beneath the surface and so you can
also take those numbers and put them
across and look at the brexit vote
across those seats so this is the way
that people voted in the referendum last
time in 2016 all the way from those who
voted for remain on this side of the
axis moving through to those who voted
more for leave so this is taking all of
those constituencies and plotting them
against that axis we can also look
actually when it comes all all sorts of
different measures as well so we have
deprivation as well this is the
deprivation ranking a kind of
traditional cloth based ranking about
all the constituencies around the UK
again for the most deprived through to
the least deprived over here and will
have all sorts of other ways of being
able to drill into those seats and show
some unexpected parallels so for
instance consider a couple of
constituencies you've got Hazel Grove
and North East Somerset they're 180
miles apart both with many similarities
so both voted 52% for Breck's you can
see that on the top you can see there
are other similarities as well virtually
the same proportion of graduates so
there's a measure of Education as well
for each of these constituency the same
proportion of people under the age of 45
so there's an aged measure as well and
very similar numbers of people have an
ethnic minority as well 3% in heylia
Hazel Grove and then you've got about 2%
just over 2 percent in Somerset
northeast question we'll be able to
answer tonight is could those
similarities could all of this data
give us a pointer as to how people will
actually vote you are well-prepared and
I think you're going to need to be you
are watching the brexit election live on
Sky News in a moment we'll have more on
our special guest tonight's speaker John
Burke oh do you know who this is
probably
the UK no well we'll be discovering how
far the fame of the most high-profile
parliamentarian of modern times has
spread and of course speak to the man
himself
[Music]
you're watching the brexit election on
Sky News as around 40 minutes to go now
until the polls close and the fate of
the 3321 candidates in total running in
this election across the UK is sealed
not among them for the first time in 22
years is the man sitting next to me John
Bercow was first elected as an MP back
in 1997 and for the past 10 years has
been of course the House of Commons
speaker he's become much more than that
though a symbol perhaps off Parliament
and a phenomenon whose fame has spread
well beyond Westminster indeed beyond
the shores take a look do you know who
this is
Prime Minister UK No
[Music]
[Applause]
we are like some sort of extravagant tie
maybe just a dead rant
spare us the theatrics stop naturally
acquire man difference of opinion is of
the essence of politics your strong
views a lot of things so he'd liked
debating quite frankly young man you can
like it or lump it has always been a
divisive figure whenever he's done
anything he's never done it by halves
he's in it with absolute commitment
ruthless efficiency and along the way
there's been some collateral damage
I really insist through some beauty and
middest myself Prime Minister's question
his expression is a little bit funny and
it is take by few musics combination of
finger wagging and head shaking going on
very rude the members order
[Applause]
[Music]
have a lie-down if necessary you really
are a very very very generous bunch of
people indeed for the state of my throat
which is purely temporary is not down to
the consumption of a kangaroo's testicle
[Music]
if debates must be conducted in a scene
[Applause]
members order order and you needed in
every country you need in every country
order it's a good it's a good word and
here he is watching all that the man
himself John Bercow and John as I say
welcome once again to Sky News election
night so there was some pretty weak
attempts there at bringing everything to
order could could you bring this
election night studio if I was to week
I shall a spa Dermot to be strong maybe
I shall have to speak more loudly or
more regularly or more insistently but
of course you are in the chair and you
are calling me to order rather than the
other way around indeed indeed I'm not
sure I'll be able to match that but it
could be useful with some of the
politicians we're going to have on the
program during the course of the evening
I'll just set sat you on them tell me
though I mean watching that you
genuinely are an international phenomena
and they would students they're from
Belgium people from all over the world
some of them thinking you might have
been the Prime Minister were you aware
of that while you were in that I became
aware of it only very late in the day it
wasn't planned it wasn't contrived it
was no part of my mission to become
known throughout Europe or indeed for
that matter
beyond for much of the time you're
almost hermetically sealed from the
outside world when you are chairing
debates for many many many hours
uninterrupted so if you want speed did I
give a thought to that the answer's no I
suppose what brought it home to me was
my family and in particular my children
if they take the mickey out familiar
with all this saying to me oh it's very
funny dad have you seen the mash up and
i said i beg your pardon what is the
mash up of x you speak i'd never heard
of a mash up and then there was
reference to memes that were audible and
could be viewed what they get out they
get out their phones and show you it is
absolutely and of course there are
streets ahead of me and all of these
messes so I eventually became aware and
I must confess that at one point much
earlier this year I went to Amsterdam to
do a late-night television program
and I was completely taken aback by two
things first I arrived at the airport
and about 10 people came up who had
arrived on other flights in pursuit of
selfies and then as we went out of the
airport there was a little crowd of
waiting taxi drivers expecting business
and one of them saw me and called our
order order and you put him right there
just very quickly John I mean much more
to discuss you in the course of the
evening and not too much politics though
of course before 10 o'clock and the
polls closing you know what are you
gonna do now you're out of politics what
what is a book one imagines and public
speaking things like that well my first
challenge
Dover's and it's quite a serious and
heavy one is to overcome my natural
shyness reticence and self-effacement
indeed if I can accomplish that task
which I will go about with some
commitment and vigor you're pretty much
on the right track I written a book I'm
doing a lot of public speaking and I
suppose if I tried to encapsulate it in
a nutshell I want to earn a living have
some fun and do some good okay I can see
we're in for quite a night the shy
retiring John Burke oh they're much more
from him of course coming up well let's
get back now to the constituencies we
visited the seats of the leaders of the
conservative and labor parties as you
know the Lib Dems are next and my
colleague Neil Patterson is gonna be
tracking Joe Swinson this evening what's
the mood there Neil
well evening determine perhaps the
biggest surprise of the general election
Sky News have sent the guy with the
Scottish accent to Scotland to Bishop
Briggs in fact and whilst I may be a
long way from home welcome to the
leisure drum yes that is what this
building is called where the count for
the constituency of Eastern Partnership
is being held this evening it was one as
you mentioned back in 2017 by one Jo
Swenson no of course at leader of the
Liberal Democrats she wasn't back then
with the SNP in second place and they do
tend to be pretty snappy with their
counts yeah last time out in 2017 Joyce
Winston's name was read out and around
about 20 to 3 and I'm told they're going
to be trying to do even better this time
around
of course people have been voting
elsewhere across Scotland so we can take
you briefly to adding Stern and South
line at show whereas you soon see one
the sturgeon I was fulfilling hard
democratic duty and casting a horror for
a little earlier on today she's of
course not standing as an MP in the
general election she's probably got
quite a bit on her plate being First
Minister but to bring you back here to
the Laird room as I said we're expecting
that came from the chief executive of
it's like the of the Eastern Partnership
Council and around about three o'clock
this morning we will certainly be
bringing you that live when it happens
and we'll have plenty more to talk about
after the polls close and watch just a
little under half an hour's time indeed
okay Neil thank you very much indeed and
you're watching the brexit election on
Sky News in a moment we'll cross two
more of the seats where the election
will be decided including one close to
my special guests heart as we count down
to ten o'clock welcome back you're
watching the brexit election on Sky News
with less than half an hour to go now
until the polls close let me take you
through the headlines and Boris Johnson
has returned to Downing Street after
voting in London this morning after
voting in Islington in North London
earlier the Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
has left his home tonight he's due to
hear the result from his constituency
run about two o'clock in the morning and
from the nationalist parties Nicola
Sturgeon voted in South Lanarkshire and
applied Camrys leader Adam Price voted
in Comanche
[Music]
now then for the first time ever Sky
News will have journalists at every
count across the country to make sure we
bring you the results as soon as they're
declared we've heard about Newcastle and
Sunderland but where else might we hear
from earlier in the evening well skies
Helen Anne Smith is in Swindon and
Caterina vertice is in Wrexham let's
start with you Helen are now and you're
in the first seat which declared in 2017
outside Sunderland and Newcastle do they
have similar hopes on timing this time
quite possibly there are two seats being
counted two declared here in Swindon
South Swindon and North Swindon back in
2017 both of those constituencies were
won by the conservative candidates and
in both cases labour were the runners-up
now it's worth saying discounts being
held in the steam railway museum here in
Swindon you might be able to see the
beautiful atrium behind me lots of
accounting offices just starting to
arrive it's the site of the old railway
works here now when this plant closed
back in the late eighties that had a
huge impact on Swindon fast forward 30
years it's now the Honda manufacturing
car plant due to closed in 2021 with a
loss of 3,500 jobs that as you say
Dermot the reason these constituencies
are worth watching is because
historically they have been some of the
first southern constituencies to declare
I just had a quick word with the
returning officer she says there might
be a little slower this year they've got
a new venue a few fewer counting
officers but nevertheless what happens
here may give us some indication of what
the night has in store
indeed okay Helen and thank you very
much daddy let's go to Caterina vacati
they're in Wrexham ER and Caterina
Wrexham traditionally one of the first
seats to declare in Wales
yeah we're expecting a return for
Wrexham at about two a and there are two
counts happening here at the Glen dear
University Sports Hall Wrexham and quids
South were expecting Wrexham first foot
south a little bit after that as I said
welcome to the University Sports Hall
where even just half an hour ago someone
was fitting a last-minute treadmill
session in the gym just to my right but
the faint whiff of workout is
slowly epping away instead replaced by
heavy throm of excitement as the vote
counters arrive to start their task in
about 20 minutes time also a Wrexham
anchored South those two counts
happening here labour held seats in 2017
will that change at this time around
expect that results at around 2 a.m.
okay Katerina thank you very much indeed
glad the whiff of workout is dissipating
in Wrexham well as I said Sky News has
people in every constituency tonight to
bring you the results as and when they
are declared that's just a sample of
some of them it's fair to say that one
of them is especially relevant to my
special guest this evening John Burke Oh
was the MP for buckingham for more than
20 years 22 in fact understood in no
less than eight elections John de frst
will just tell us about the the life of
a constituency MP particularly at
general election time though those
nerves well it's great privilege to be a
constituency MP and I'll never forget
the feeling of elation and relief when I
was first elected the result declared at
10:00 to 6:00 in the morning on the
second of May 1997 but you reference
that point Dermot about nerves and the
truth is that I think the vast majority
of candidates are afflicted by what is
known in the trade as candidate itis
that is to say they are nervous and
sometimes neurotic even if there is no
obviously discernible reason why they
should be even if you're in a pretty
safe seat or a very safe seat you still
think oh did something go wrong did
something happen in this particular
constituency that could unseat me yes
and I think that's true at various
stages in the campaign for example you
can have a bad day I remember in 1997
having a bad day and a bad day meant
meeting people who had previously voted
conservative and in some cases always
voted conservative saying they weren't
going to vote conservative I remember
going to dinner one night with my age
and in a local pub and he obviously
anticipated what I was thinking I was
looking pretty miserable and forlorn and
I said to him Gordon you don't think no
John he said to me and I said but Gordon
you don't know what I'm going
asked you and he said I think I know
exactly yeah question is on the tip of
your tongue he said you're about to ask
me might you lose and I said yes I was
going to ask that and he said no John it
is gonna be a tough election but on a
uniform swing the Conservative Party
would have to be down to seven seats to
lose Bucky and that's not gonna happen
worry not he said and enjoy your dinner
well a lot of worried candidates out
there tonight and tonight Sky News is
producing not one but two election
programs we're on Sky News across the UK
and worldwide on TV and Sky's mobile
platforms but we're also delivering the
brexit election social across social
media networks set for more let's join
Sky's political correspondent Lewis
Goodall he's presenting the election
social it begins in just a few minutes
time only you Lewis yes indeed dammit
we're in a parallel universe to you from
over here very very close though just
over the balcony and this is a we were
first for Britain a digital-only
election program aimed or all of those
people who obsessively live their lives
online and all of the election geeks and
I daresay I might include myself in that
as well but don't worry it's not just me
I'm not like Macaulay Culkin I'm not
home alone I've got a whole panel a vast
panoply of the internet service and best
and most knowledgeable at least that's
what we've they've told us anyway who
will be guiding us throughout the night
seeing what people are saying online and
as I say as well bringing you the very
geekiest Assefa logical analysis
available and the best thing about it is
dumb it is that everyone can enjoy your
program as well it's a main course a
meaty coniferous main course to our
luscious vegan millennial side dish so
make sure you join us on Sky News
digital platforms across the internet
complimentary okay Louis good luck thank
you very much now the unsung heroes of
election night are the teams up these
local councils collecting and counting
all the millions of ballot papers all in
an attempt to make sure we know the
election result by round about breakfast
tomorrow we're going to hear from two of
them now first a Newcastle and my
colleague Julie and Joseph Gillian
Dermot thank you yes they are the unsung
heroes and it's not just about declaring
the results on the night I have with me
Pat Ritchie who's been the returning
officer for Newcastle for the last eight
years and we were talking a little bit
before it this is the culmination of
many many months of workers not yes
really this is the end of the process
where staff involved in the election
have been working right through from
when the announcement of the election
was made taking nominations organizing
polling stations working on postal votes
issue in postal votes dealing with
hundreds and thousands of queries from
the public about registration and about
voting and really when we get to the
count that's the end of the hall of the
democratic process although one of the
the most important parts of it explain
to us what it's like for you when you're
up on that stage and you know the result
and you're about to share that with the
rest of the world is it nerve-wracking
for you well it's quite a responsibility
really you know and it's it's quite and
I'm quite proud of being involved in a
you know a number of Democratic events
really and it's sort of nerve-wracking
but actually the organization of the
election and some of the things that we
rode on is in some ways more of
nerve-wracking when you get to that
stage it's about really delivering the
result on behalf of the the people of
Newcastle really actually thank you very
much for talking to us there Pat we
shoot a returning officer for Newcastle
we shall be back to you a little later
on in the program Dermot yeah and see if
they've done it Gillian thank you very
much indeed that's New Castle's hopes
set let's see what they're doing in
Sunderland Sarah Jane is there can they
beat them Sarah Jane
well there quietly confident I have to
say derma I'm with the returning officer
here in Sunderland Patrick Melia Patrick
hello to you
very exciting night tonight how are the
nerves nerves are fine no notes at all
it's you've got a well efficient
well-run team here so looking forward to
the evening
it's interesting how is the rivalry with
Newcastle because in the 2017 election I
mean I hate to remind you but they
didn't pick me to be the first to
declare and when Pat popped up Pat
Ritchie there you and I know Pat yes but
a rivalry is when you impact together
that's right it's all about the
efficient accurate election nothing else
coming first is not the main thing I
think that the important thing is for
the electorate and for the candidates
it's a smooth efficient operation to
give the accurate results okay I mean
the buzz in this room
I mean it's making me nervous I know
you've got nerves of steel when can we
expect the first boxes to arrive because
looking at that countdown clock we've
got just under 15 minutes to go so we're
in the Horton and Sundance outcomes
tissue seems over right in the center of
that constituency nice applause should
end up here three minutes past 10:00
they stores will burst over the doors
will burst open and your feet a box come
through the door now a lot of practice
goes into this office there's so much
build-up in a general election campaign
two voting day but in terms of
practicing what goes on here in this
hall you have local schoolchildren
helping you out there's a relay going on
outside there in the cold and the rain
yet know that local sixth-form seat
isn't st. Anthony's every year the sixth
floor must turn up and they help us
whether it's a local election or a
national election with the relay getting
the ballot boxes from the vans into the
building to the right place within the
building and it's great just to see them
being involved in the democratic process
and it all comes in here twenty-eight
teams and how many counts is each team
so it's around 12 to countless lives to
you but across the board we have around
300 counters the cost of three different
constituencies and their fingers are at
the ready for three minutes past 10:00
we'll be having our eyes on those doors
at the back of this room as they burst
open those boxes come in Patrick good
luck to you Patrick melee returning
officer I know you're watching that
countdown clock you've got to go so
let's go be knighted thank you right
well that is it from the Sunderland for
moment will keeping our eye on that
countdown clock because as I said
they're quietly confident that they're
going to be first to declare tonight
okay
Sara J Gillian best of luck to you both
I'm staying neutral on this one and
you're watching the brexit election on
Sky News just 13 minutes to go now until
10 o'clock and we can bring you the exit
poll whose hopes could be dashed tonight
okay you're watching the brexit election
on Sky News and there are just nine
minutes to go until polls close and we
bring you the results of the
broadcaster's exit poll well we've heard
from the constituency counts of the
leaders of the Conservatives labour and
Lib Dems and the place is vying to be
first Sky News is live at more than 200
counts tonight and these six are amongst
them James Matthews is in Glasgow David
Blevins is in Belfast Katie Spencer is
in Brighton Knoll Phillips is in
Kensington and Gerrard tub is in
Hartlepool and into mam Rashida's in
what from snow in Northeast London to
you first James Glasgow is ever a key
place of course we'll be watching for
tonight that's right yeah well from
there the cavernous SEC on the banks of
the River Clyde Dermot the stage about
half a mile behind me here on the media
platform 59 seats being decided across
Scotland this evening here in Glasgow
there will be seven six held last time
run by the SNP one by Labour a record
number of people in Scotland just over
four million registered to vote in this
election before the November the 26th
deadline the weather I'm happy to say
has been kind to them voters have been
spared the worst of a Scottish December
that's not to say there hasn't been
disruption mind you there was a
controlled explosion in Northland ature
of what's being described as a
non-viable device outside a room that
was going to be used by voters they had
to be diverted a 48 year old man has
been charged in connection with that
incident okay James that's good about
fast every Blevins is there and David
tell us about the counts there
well it's a different selection of
parties for voters to choose from here
in this corner of the United Kingdom but
that doesn't mean they are less relevant
there are 18 seats in Northern Ireland
back in 2017 the DUP won ten of them
shin fence seven and an independent
candidate the 18th here in Belfast
itself
the DUP is tonight defending three of
the four seats and shin fin won so
whether it's from mana
and South Tyrone the most westerly
constituency in the UK or Antrim north
just 20 miles from Scotland on this side
of the Irish Sea we will bring you all
the results from Northern Ireland as
they come in and we expect them all
declared by about 3 o'clock ok David
thanks for that ter Katie Spencer is in
bright tonight where we'll see the Green
Party's Caroline Lucas later Katie yeah
well other counts are racing to be among
the first to return a result sadly I
think that's not something you'll see us
taking part in here at the Brighton
Centre we've got form for being a bit
late to really win through adults when
they come in so you'll see that
electoral juggernaut have hundreds of
votes coming in between three and about
five we're more likely to deliver a
result some time we think between five
and about seven in the morning but
they're all gearing up they're all
getting into place it's three
constituencies that were counting for
here Hove which in 2017 went to labour
and I'll just step out the way so you
can see some of the other areas that
we're going to be getting the count for
so ever to the right they're going to be
counting for a Brighton Kemp town which
also went to labour and in the middle is
where they're going to be doing the
count for Caroline what was Caroline
Lucas is constituency in 2017 which gave
the Green there only seat in the House
of Commons Katie thanks very much NOLA
Phillips is in Kensington in West London
one of the London seats we're going to
be watching very closely tonight aren't
we no indeed at them welcome to
Kensington and at Chelsea Town Hall and
now and short announcement
a moment ago there that's why the round
of applause around 500 people employed
here to ensure this election goes
according to plan and the last that
we're expecting results around 4:30 this
morning but beyond these walls this is a
constituency that is quite affluent it's
Nate you know there are people here who
live in deprived communities as well but
one of the things one of the most
defining things about this constituency
is the fact that it is a mile or so away
from Kensington Palace home to members
of the royal family and of course we're
expecting as I said the results around
4:30 this morning ok no thanks for that
sure let's go to Hartlepool chair our
table is so live there and it's where
the chairman of the brexit party richard
theis is standing isn't it Joe
we're going to have some excitement here
we're hoping later on certainly a lot of
people wanting to see what the result is
going to be here course Hartlepool North
East Coast's between Middlesbrough and
Newcastle 71 thousand voters here it's
people who from this town known as the
monkey hangers of 200 year old insult
from the Napoleonic Wars when they found
a shipwrecked monkey on the beach
thought it was a French spy they've
never seen a monkey or a Frenchman and
so they hanged it but it shows something
of a spirit of the people here that
they're quite proud of that richard
theis of course as you say wants to be
the MP will this constituency that voted
that heavily for leave let him have his
way okay Jared thank you very much
indeed now in Samarra she'd is in
Walthamstow
in North East London and in zoo mama
boxes arriving very soon
that's right welcome to Walthamstow
townhall complex there's gonna be three
counts here overnight mid we first got
swole from Stowe then we've got Layton
and once they're both labor seats in the
last general election and then Chingford
and Woodford green now that's probably
the most noticeable one with Ian Duncan
Smith the former leader of the
Conservative Party standing in that
constituency once again he's been the MP
for that constituency
since it was first created 22 years ago
so no doubt we'll be seeing him in this
hall tonight now the voters the counters
are all there behind us waiting for
those ballot papers to come in and get
counting after 10 p.m. it may be cliche
to say dammit but it looks like it's a
kind of grab the popcorn kind of night
here in Walthamstow okay it could be
Inzamam thank you very much indeed well
the moment is fast approaching when the
voting stops and we can bring you the
results of the broadcaster's exit poll
let's look at that countdown precisely
now three minutes in fact until we
reveal the findings of this huge
exercise carried out today by the
pollsters Ipsos MORI on behalf of us
here at Sky News the BBC and ITV News
canvases have interviewed thousands of
people in 144 different place
is across the country well here with me
is our political editor beth rigby so
others say well under three minutes to
go that under three minutes go and i'm
so nervous about it about this exit poll
because this is as you said the moment
when you're not asking people how they
intend to vote how they did vote and
it's the first moment where we get a
sense of how well or badly the parties
have done there's a margin it comes up
in seats one there's a margin of error
of twenty on either side but certainly
in the past three elections it's been
pretty on the money it can change the
narrative and it can surprise us well we
will find out now looking at the clock
again let's count down to the two-minute
warning two minutes to go until we can
reveal the results of the exit poll who
will return to Westminster with the
mandate to form a government or could
voters deliver and now that hung
parliament we'll be getting that
indication very soon your feelings john
burke oh it will be an exciting moment
it isn't absolutely proof positive of
what will happen but it's a pretty clear
guiding light so somebody is going to be
very elated and somebody is going to be
very dejected you've been sitting at
home presumably I'm watching it in
previous elections in previous elections
I've sometimes watched at home but more
often I have been out of dinner
preparing to go to the council indeed of
course okay John thank you very much
indeed for that we are focusing on that
clock again as it marches relentlessly
towards ten o'clock precisely there's
just over one minute to go now until we
release the broadcasters exit poll now
you don't know what it will say we don't
know what it will say it's shot
politicians and the public on recent
election nights and despite their doubts
predicted the direction of the elections
certainly last time around in 2017 when
it predicted that Theresa May would fall
short well will it do the same tonight
there are only moments left to wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's ten o'clock the brexit election is
over and it looks like this
the exit poll is predicting is
indicating it's a conservative win that
the Conservatives will have 368 seats
the Labour Party 191 the Liberal
Democrats we're getting 13 the brexit
party on 0 Scottish National Party 55
and the Greens on one that others will
have 22 so there it is the exit poll
predicting a big conservative win a
majority for Boris Johnson the initial
reactions better eating while Boris
Johnson called this the brexit election
and really if that is the result tonight
he has won emphatically an incredible
result if it's correct and it means that
we will leave the EU next year Brooks it
will happen okay well there we are the
exit poll is indicating that the
Conservatives will gain 368 seats the
Labour Party 191 the Lib Dems 13 that
would we just got one more since in
since that they started the last
Parliament with the SNP will be on 55
well let's get reaction from John Bercow
a big majority as Beth was saying there
I think those bigger spell an 86
majority so if that's accurate
that is a phenomenal victory for the
Conservative Party and Boris Johnson
would obviously feel completely
vindicated in the gamble that he took
that is much more emphatic than some of
the polls have suggested but it would be
an absolutely dramatic victory and it
certainly would mean as Beth says that
he would be in a position to get phase
one of brexit done by the end of January
there's a much wider debate but that is
undoubtedly well let's say let's a stay
without headline it's an exit poll no
seats have declared of course yet but
that exit poll suggesting the Boris
Johnson will have one and one big
suggesting the Conservatives will have
368 seats Jeremy Corbyn and labour on
one
91 one of those responsible for
tonight's exit poll is Sky's election
analyst professor Michael thrash and now
he's tracked every election for us since
Sky News was founded he's now on his way
here to the sky election center from
central London he was involved in
compiling that exit poll and Michael
tell us more about it well it's been a
remarkable day Dermott we've been taking
interviews from across the country since
7 o'clock this morning right the way
through until just before the polling
stations closed and the Conservatives
have been heading for an overall
majority all day long it's just that the
number has fluctuated down as more
labour voters perhaps turned out to vote
later on but it really is a remarkable
election victory for Boris Johnson and a
majority of 86 seats for labour it
really is an appalling an election
result and possibly its worst
performance in any general election
since the Second World War
so Jeremy Corbyn I'm afraid will go down
as one of the worst leaders in Labour's
history and Michael does it give us any
indication yet of the areas to look out
for where this will or may happen very
much so it's it's quite clear that the
more constituencies voted to leave the
EU in 2016 the better the performance
for the Conservatives so the
Conservatives are going to gain seats
across the Midlands and northern England
these are areas where traditionally
labour has held sway and and it's in
these areas where the Labour vote has
fallen most the conservative vote has
written the most so it's in the former
industrial towns of the Midlands and the
north where lay where labour have really
suffered and they will lose many
constant many the constituencies that
they had gained to lose over 70 they
will be lost in these areas
and Michael some discussion of course
about the the seats of some of the
leaders in particular Boris Johnson and
Joe Swenson any thoughts about what
might happen in those seats well in
terms of Joe Swenson and Scotland
Scotland is fascinating in general
because although you've got the
Conservatives easily winning the most
seats in England and Wales in Scotland
it is the SNP that prevail we're
suggesting that they are very close to
their peak when they won 56 seats we
we're suggesting that they're going to
win 55 some of those gains are from the
Conservatives some are from Labour and
some from the Liberal Democrats in other
words all the all the parties that were
in favour a reach of remaining in the
scholar remaining in the Union they've
all suffered defeats at the hands of the
SNP okay Michael I know you're
hotfooting it towards us here in the
studio see you very soon well what do
the Conservatives make off tonight's
exit poll the Tory party chairman James
cleverly is here with me now well
whatever the exit poll says you always
come in and say take it with a pinch of
salt are you treating this one that way
well I've always felt that polls should
be taken with a degree of caution we've
we've seen over a number of electoral
events over the last year's than call it
wrong I've been cautious of poll results
when they've looked good on cautious of
poll results when they look not so good
so we'll see how the seats actually roll
out before I start getting too excited
about okay indeed but let's go without
indication that will be a thumping
majority welcomes any Willie if it comes
anywhere close to that
well maths is math and if big if if the
numbers play out as per that exit poll
then that is numerically a big majority
but as I say we'll want to see yeah if
it plays out and also we'll want to see
which particular constituencies have
voted in what way well what about your
sense of the way it was going on the
campaign trail I mean a lot of an awful
lot of labour seats according to the
exit poll will come your way
presumably seats that have
never been conservative before did you
get that sense while you were out
campaigning yeah and it was difficult
really to assess it's still difficult to
assess exactly how that feeling will
play out but I spent much of this week
over the weekend early part of this week
zigzagging across the Midlands the north
of England and in long-standing labour
held constituencies there was fury I
mean not anger fury at both the Labour
Party and at Jeremy Corbyn a lot of
people felt that they were lied to in
2017 when the Labour candidates look
them in the eye and said I will deliver
brexit and then spent the following two
and a half years doing everything to
prevent it but more than that there was
a feeling that the Labour Party had
stopped talking about and talking to
those communities and was focusing very
very much on basically its big urban
constituencies and what about leadership
do you think Boris Johnson just went
down better than Jeremy Corbyn well
Boris is very good at reaching out to
people I I've been on the campaign trail
with him a number of times in 2008 when
he won the London merits against
expectations in 2012 when he London won
the London marilee against expectations
in in the referendum which was won
against expectations and we're seeing
now hopefully if these numbers play out
that he has got a the working majority
that we've asked the British people to
give us so he can get brexit done and
then focus on the priority and there I
hear on the door sand that Sunderland
trying to be first let me bring in a man
now who you know very well mr. Corelli
yeah
former Speaker John Burke oh and John
Burke I mean this would be if it turns
out this way it's only the exit poll
this would be a majority of facture
right proportions yes I mean it would be
stratospherically higher than a lot of
people including quite a lot of
conservative optimists had predicted
it's not quite in the domain of Margaret
Thatcher's 101 in 87 oh no 144 in 1983
but it is nevertheless a very very very
satisfactory result for the Conservative
Party if that is what if it's against
and Beth Rigby it's the fourth time of
asking as well to actually put on seats
if this we've got to keep saying it's
the active delt but this is exactly
let's just I mean a year ago Boris
Johnson was
on the back benches and he almost looked
didn't he James like like a busted flush
I mean this is an incredible political
combat for Boris Johnson for a start
I mean unbelievably impressive if you
think if that is correct if that poll is
correct he is the most successful
conservative prime minister since
Margaret Thatcher I mean you haven't
seen majorities like that for decades
and then the other thing I would say in
terms of labor if they have gone back in
that sort of level I mean that's worse
than the Michael foot performance then
Jeremy Corbyn is going to have to resign
I mean that if that is correct he has to
resign and he can't stay on as leader
well will be obviously putting those
kind of questions to the labor
representative when they come in but
we've got James clarity from the
Conservatives here right now are they
popping any champagne corks they all
cliche out are you just gonna sit back
and watch the results come in this is
boring and it makes terrible television
and I apologize in advance thank you
you're going to wait for the numbers
yeah the real numbers the real votes
from real constituencies because until
that happens I mean this may well be
very well informed speculation but it is
speculation my job the promise that I
made to the prime minister is to give
him a working majority that's what we're
working towards and if that comes off
and I'll be very pretty
but back in 2015 when David Cameron eke
- what 12 seat majority it felt like a
massive achievement I mean what has
happened it if that is correct
are loads of labour voters lending the
Conservatives their vote because they
want to get brexit done ie do you think
that the brexit identity of voters has
completely trounced traditional party
identities in this election I think that
is part of it that is part of it but I
think there's something deeper I think
for years perhaps decades there have
been people who voted labour and they've
seen the Labour Party drift further and
further away from them spend less and
less time talking about the things that
they value spend less and less time
talking about the parts of the country
that they live in and have knocked on
the door and just expected those people
to continue voting labour and I think
brexit vote was a wake-up call because
it was Labour's reaction to their vote
that I think was toxic so rather than
saying oh my gosh we've we've stopped
listening to you we'll listen to you now
we want to understand why you're upset
why you're angry why you're fearful we
had senior voices from the Labour Party
ridiculing those values and it's Italy I
mean is it going to change the
Conservative Party if you have addressed
different constituencies and attracted
to them they attracted to your manifesto
do you have to be a different party my
contention is that that under Boris's
leadership we are already becoming
different we are evolving and I've
always felt very proud of the
Conservative Party because it's a party
that evolves and through his leadership
campaign Boris said that we need to
spread opportunity around the whole of
the UK that we need to make sure that
parts of the country that are not
well-connected in public transport terms
get better connected to to raise the
attainment of schools in in parts of the
country outside London the South East he
was saying this during his leadership
campaign I think people have been
listening to that which is why we've
seen since the summer of this year a
steady increase in the support for the
Conservative Party yes in our
traditional areas like my lovely part of
North Essex but also where I was earlier
on this week in in in Durham and in
Newcastle in in Cumbria and in the West
Midlands and in the northeast and the
northwest and in North Wales but if they
sexy apparel is to be believed there
that's the kind of places as you say mr.
Greville you are going to start winning
seats but Sir those results still to
come in thank you very much a deep for
the time being will it get off to your
count and oh we wanted reaction from the
Labour Party we've got Labour's Barry
Gardner joining us now the shadow
secretary state for international trade
your mood mr. Gardner or what do you
make of this if it is to be a hundred
and ninety one seats if that is the case
then obviously it's a devastating result
for us and not just for us it's not just
about our party or the the people who've
worked so hard to support the Labour
Party this is about all the people who
were really needing
laborer victory to improve their lives
in so many ways the people who needed
decent housing the people who needed
decent schools for their children that
were properly funded people in need of
the health service or social care and
and I think we we offered a manifesto of
hope and manifesto that had was full of
integrity and if this is the result then
many many people that are going to be
very let down you're not questioning the
numbers then you think okay mine I'll be
191 but even if it's 20 seats or so more
it's still awful isn't it look I'm not
I'm it's not clear of what what it will
be but certainly this exit poll is a
devastating blow and obviously as the
night wears on we'll know exactly
whether it's as bad as it suggests or
not but it certainly doesn't look good
and I think in one sense we always knew
that this election was going to be
focused on brexit and that is the
strategy that the Conservatives played
most general elections are of course
about all those other issues and this
one has tended to focus almost
exclusively on the the issue of brexit
okay and that seems to have cut across
the traditional lines of politics but if
this is the number it's it's
catastrophic for labour is it not it's
worse results since before the war since
1935 in actual fact have you spoken to
Jeremy Corbyn yet no I haven't obviously
I rushed here to to get to the studios
and and I've been here since since 10
o'clock listening to to the results but
obviously it's a it's a deeply
depressing prediction and as I say it's
one that really my heart goes out to all
the people who had had given their hope
to the Labour Party who really were
relying on us to be able to improve
their lives and sort out the problems
that they were facing and and that's
what pains me the most about a
projection like this but that's the
thing you let them down
what you didn't offer them what they
seem to want did you well I I do believe
that for many people we were offering
what what they they needed and wanted I
think as I say brexit rather overlaid
all of that and of course the the
conservative manifesto simply focused on
brexit and you know okay maybe a
singular message was the one that has
won through in the end but it was a
singularly lacking envision offer from
the Conservative Party I'm proud that
our offer was as strong as it is was as
hopeful as it is and as I say I I am
deeply deeply depressed if these
projections well on these net a lot on
these numbers are you touching on their
mr. Gardner you need to reinvent the
party and doesn't that start at the top
I mean you you need a new leader you
can't lose twice and these the second
time as badly as this look I mean
obviously these are things that will be
discussed by the leadership of the party
in the next few days it's prematurity to
be discussing them now at the moment we
must see exactly what the night holds
and you know I I hope that many many of
my colleagues will will retain their
seats that the predictions will not
prove true because I know every one of
them has fought a campaign full of
integrity full of honesty and full of
compassion and and that's what is most
to to the fore of my mind at the moment
that we will not be able to deliver that
compassionate hopeful agenda for the
people in our country and desperately
needed it alright shadow secretary state
thank you very much indeed Labor's Barry
Gardner there well let's see what those
exit poll numbers mean for Parliament's
over to Ed Conway well I mean blimey
blimey I mean let's get the provisos out
of the way first
you know this is an exit poll there are
lots of question marks over you know it
may not necessarily be fully reliable
but over the past few decades it
certainly has been let's have a look
though at those numbers provisos out the
way 368 seats for the Conservatives it's
not just a good night a great night for
the Tories Boris Johnson could win 368
we'll give them a majority in government
quite clearly actually have a look how
that actually works out so there we have
the numbers but let's put them into our
kind of virtual House of Commons so
there you have it it's our government
builder essentially taking all of those
parties all of those results this is
from the exit poll let's put the
conservative numbers into the government
benches as it were so those hexagons
represent government benches and that
line look at that line that's 326 seats
it takes the Tories comfortably pass the
total they require to get into Danny's
seat you'll remember that winning line
we showed you earlier on the line into
Downing Street according to the exit
poll Boris Johnson is safely in but it
is of course according to the exit poll
now the poll also suggesting maybe even
more of a story labour to get a hundred
and ninety-one seats leaving them short
obviously of being able to form a
coalition challenge the Conservative
Party historically bad worse since the
second world war as you were hearing you
were talking to Debbie Barry garden or a
moment ago and many people think we'll
think that's pretty disastrous for the
Labour Party let's just go back though
that's the exit poll let's go back and
remember the picture in 2017 okay so
have a look at this will show you the
results last time around so 2017 the
Tories 318 short of that majority there
you can see the board on the Left Labour
262 so up above 200 that time around and
then you can see the map behind that's
the map as of before today the map of
the UK the political map is about to be
redrawn let's clear that it's clear so
we're starting afresh and throughout the
evening that map's gonna be very
important because we're going to be
keeping a very close eye on
constituencies around the country there
you can see them dotted so those
constituencies around the country will
be looking at to see if that exit poll
is on track or not that's what we all
want to know an extraordinary number big
reaction from markets as well which will
bring you in a second
but let's have a look what we can do is
not just give you the overall number but
some of them names that we might well
focus on that might be part of the story
tonight Bolsover
Dennis Skinner in 2017 the Tories
managed to actually double their votes
in bowls over it's 70 percent leave
area the toys have been very keen on
guessing that seat well we can tell you
that according to the exit poll Bolsover
is likely to fall to the Tories so the
Tories will win bowls over says the exit
poll now that is just what the exit poll
is suggesting we'll have to see whether
the results actually bear that out and
we'll have earlier results that can give
you a sense of that but that is what the
exit poll suggests at the moment then as
Skinner's had that seat since 1950
extraordinary moment for the Labour do
iron there there are other potential
losses actually when you look at the
north as well so you got stoke-on-trent
labour since 1950 Wrexham Lee Lee as
well labour since 1922 but have a look
at this okay in London cities of London
and Westminster could be better news
here for labour of other day they've
been targeting and this really shows
your underlines the fact that we're not
just talking about a uniform spring
where it's all going to the Tories way
there are some seats actually where
labour may well actually do well now at
the moment this is the thesis of mark
field who stood down at the election
there was a nine-point swing from the
Tories to labour in 2017 but get this
the exit polls suggesting it's not going
to continue in this election it could go
to the Labour Party so chuck omana from
the Liberal Democrats was hoping to win
the seat now according to the exit poll
again provisos we've got them out the
way that's going to go to labour isn't
that extraordinary that was the seat
that Chuck Romano was hoping to win but
they're actually poor suggesting that's
looking good for labour we're not going
to give you the exact numbers because
then that would be slightly spurious at
this stage but what we're telling you is
that's what the exit poll is suggesting
extraordinary results here elsewhere
have a look out in London for Putney
wooden buildin like they could also
actually go to labour as well and now
obviously the race is on so we've
cleared the board and the race is now on
for the first MP to be confirmed in
Parliament these are the contenders you
can see every year it's a race between
Newcastle horns you could do custom all
the time central and Houghton and
Sunderland South there they are
last time around it was Cheon whare in
newcastle upon tyne central who was
announced first shortly before her
colleague bridget philipson in Houghton
and Sunderland South the big question of
course is who will it be this time
around Dermot and will those results
bear out what we've seen in that extra
exit poll okay thank you very much a
deed extraordinary is the word if the
exit poll is to be believed let's just
talk you through those numbers again 368
the indication for the Conservative
Party a huge majority for Boris Johnson
labour
pushed back under 200 on 191 well my
colleague Sam coats our deputy political
editor is looking at so many historical
comparisons been made Sam talked us
through some of them so we've been
looking under the bonnet of this
extraordinary exit poll and yes it looks
like Boris Johnson is on course to break
a number of records if this exit poll
does translate let's look first of all
at some numbers we haven't seen yet the
approximate national share of the vote
from our exit poll this suggests that
the Conservatives will end up on 46% of
the vote and labour could end up as low
as 32% now this would be a greater share
for the Conservatives than in any
election the 1970 it would also be the
first time an incumbent government had
increased its national share of the vote
in three successive elections towards 15
2017 and 2019 it looks as if there's
been a spin a swing from Labour to
conservative or 5.4 percent the previous
post-war record was Margaret Thatcher in
1979 that was 5.3 percent so it looks as
if Boris Johnson could be on course to
beat that now let's look at labour this
looks like if this exit poll is true
that the Labour Party could set a new
post-war record for the smallest number
of seats won by labour in a general
election look in 1983 the party won just
209 seats with a 28 percent vote share
in 1987 they won 229 so clearly this
exit poll puts the below that then you
look at the fact that this is a brexit
election the conservative share of the
vote has gone up in constituencies
particularly it's gone up in
constituencies that had largely votes in
2016 but that's not the only effect in
this election it does appear as if there
might have been something like had
called in effect because labour are down
even in places they might have been
expecting to do well even though labour
might pick up seats in London Labour's
vote
has fallen everywhere including London
it's just it's just in decline less in
London and then there are just some
extraordinary individual seats
themselves Lee that it formerly held by
Andy Burnham taking an enormous swing
it's been labor since 1922 that looks
under this exit poll as if it could if
it could also be lost one or two other
quick things
the SNP now they look like they're on
course to almost repeat their triumph in
2015 they looked like they're on course
for 55 seats in 2015 they got 26 seats
it could even come at the expense of Jay
Swenson the Liberal Democrat leader
it's an extraordinary exit poll pointing
to an extraordinary night could be quite
a night ahead ok Sam thanks for updating
us on that's from the exit poll John
Bercow 368 seats for Boris Johnson we've
done the historical comparisons just
give us your feelings what it might all
mean well it would be a dramatic result
and it would be a vastly better result
than most conservatives dreamt of at any
time during the campaign and probably
for some months before I would imagine
the Prime Minister would be elated
thrilled to bits dancing around the
mulberry bush in joyous appreciation of
the voters verdict if this is anywhere
near to accurate any point I would like
Dermot to pick up on from earlier is
that James cleverly quite understandably
as the Tory Party Chairman sought to
superimpose his own view at a very
formative stage of our proceedings on
how the voters might have been motivated
in voting as they did and it was quite
interesting that James said well it was
much wider than brexit the Conservative
Party had been focusing on transport and
the extension of opportunity and
enabling people to move forward and so
on and so you think it whilst brexit
that cutting message get that sense is a
bit rich the truth of the matter and it
isn't in any sense to cavil it's just to
clarify it was a brexit focused brexit
orientated brexit dominated campaign the
idea that there was any great push
through for any other subject from the
Conservatives is frankly fanciful it was
all up
that missing but the fact it's all that
narrow point then brexit does get done
ie the withdrawal agreement gets passed
if they have a majority agreement but
that Dermot is the basis is one mater
will be done and it will be possible I'm
quite sure if this result is true for
the UK to exit the European Union as the
Prime Minister wants by the end of
January 2020 but that's the withdrawal
agreement that is about the divorce bill
it's about the rights of European
citizens about the Irish border I don't
think if I may say so that means getting
brexit done in the sense that it's
gift-wrapped or oven ready for Christmas
we will be debating brexit certainly for
the next five years probably for the
next turn and conceivably for the next
but the thing it's better it be I mean
people just seem to want to stop talking
about it for the Parliament yeah and I
would say what I would say though John
about that majority of he's got a
majority that big he is going to get
brexit done because he can actually push
the terms of trade of what he wants to
do through the Commons with a majority
like that he will not have the problems
that Theresa May and Boris Johnson had
in Parliament the other thing that I
think we should have a think about in
this this isn't just about Breck's that
this could also be about the Union
because think about the SNP S&P they've
produced 50 vibed into that 55 seats
nearly back to the sort of performance
that they saw back in 2015 I think it
was when they took nearly a clean sweep
across Scotland so you're going to have
a very pro brexit conservative prime
minister pushing through what could be a
very very hard trade deal to get it done
by the end of 2020 and you have Nicola
Sturgeon in Scotland calling for a
second referendum and the country could
be another 30 to be a rare a remain so
that is going to be a fascinating
dynamic of Boris Johnson plenty more to
discuss and plenty of time to do it
because we haven't had any results yet
but wonder if we've heard from the Prime
Minister himself on Boris Johnson well
my colleague Anna botting is following
Boris Johnson tonight as she's there in
Uxbridge waiting for his cat to complete
and have we heard anything at all
from mr. Johnson Anna just in the last
moment in fact he has tweeted his thanks
to those who have worked hard in this
campaign the words of the Prime Minister
then thank you to everyone across a
great country who voted who volunteered
who stood as candidates we live in the
greatest democracy in the world no tears
in Downing Street this time remember
Theresa May the strategy back in 2017
was to go over after those labor leave
leaning seats in the end they took just
six this time it looks like that
strategy has worked and there is the
Prime Minister out in South Ruislip
earlier this evening we understand his
own count here in Uxbridge
perhaps not looking quite such a pretty
picture for the prime minister certainly
labour here claim that they have rattled
the prime minister suggesting that he's
been here more times in the last week
than they have in the last four years
but back to the overall picture then
what looks like a resounding victory for
this politician who becomes more Marmite
and or less more right and more Heineken
the politician they can reach parts of
the country that others can't well let's
go to Downing Street then our political
correspondent Kate McCann and Kate
certainly the Conservatives would have
been happy with left yes that's right
Anna so the mood in Downing Street where
all of the Boris Johnson team his top
advisers including Dominic Cummings are
here they've been watching that poll
together is still cautious actually
they're still saying it's just an exit
poll but no doubt very very pleased
indeed because this represents a really
big change we were talking earlier about
what it would look like it could mean
the Conservatives winning seats like
Darlington that would be a full point at
percentage point swing that really is
massive and I have to say we've traveled
across the country spent a lot of time
in Midland seats and in the north of the
country where lots of labour voters have
been saying to us it's only anecdotally
but that for the first time they are
going to be voting conservative brexit
is a huge part of that decision I've
just spoken to a cabinet minister in the
last couple of moments they are of
course making the point that it's just
in a bracket election poll so far but
they are saying that if this result is
what the actual final result looks
then they believe they could be taking
seats like cat Smiths in the north of
the country she has a 6600 majority at
the moment the Conservatives would need
over six thousand votes to get that seat
back that really would be a big moment
indeed and there will be other seats
like that where the Conservatives
perhaps wouldn't even have dared to
dream that they might be able to take it
this cabinet minister also said it's
important that if the Conservatives do
take those seats that they hold on to
them so they fulfill some of those
promises that James cleverly was just
talking about there okay thank you
suggestion that anything above 360 would
count as a massive electoral realignment
talk about massive swings in places like
Dudley North Don Valley working Tim
Bishop Auckland and the big question now
is should this election be taken as an
unquestionable mandate to brexit is this
the end of the road really the hopes of
remainders and certainly we'll see that
discussed and played out throughout the
night Dermot thank you very much indeed
Anna it's just after half past 10 you
watching the brexit election on Sky News
let me take you through their lines and
counting has begun in the 2019 general
election the exit poll carried out for
Sky News the BBC and ITV News predicts a
conservative win with 368 seats a
majority of 86 the exit poll is also
suggesting that Labour are set for a
hugely disappointing night with the
party forecast to secure their lowest
number of seats for many decades and as
you may just heard Boris Johnson is
tweeted tonight saying thank you to
everyone across our great country who
voted we live in the greatest democracy
in the world she was out speaking to
voters in Uxbridge tonight just before
the polls closed
[Music]
well a very disappointing night indeed
for the Labour Party if that exit poll
is correct my colleague Sophie ridges
tracking the Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
tonight what reaction from that camp
Sophie well the official reaction from
labour is that it's the very beginning
of the night things are still too early
to call when it comes to the result but
the reality of course is that they will
have seen the exit polls just like the
rest of us the 44 the Conservative Party
that's been predicted and a very poor
night for labour if that comes through
down 71 seats and speaking to someone in
team Corbin they kind of off the record
for Marcus that they have shocked and
sad the mood is of course pretty low
after seeing that exit poll result and I
think that despite the kind of official
but this is just a poll they have to
wait for those results to come through
they will know just how bad this for
them at this early stage we've also been
talking to some former Labour MP is
currently the candidates outside of
London because I feel like this is
really turning into a race of two halves
if you like a story of two hands for
Labour tonight but while the vote may be
holding up well in places like Islington
outside of London I'm told things like
and break said cutting through we'll go
now to a Jason Ferrell who's been a
tracking Jeremy Corbyn throughout the
campaign and has been following him
tonight Jason what are you hearing well
the official line from the Labour Party
is that it's too early to say as you say
they say their statement is it's only
the very beginning of the night and it's
too early to call the result we of
course knew this was going to be a
challenging election with brexit at the
forefront of many people's minds and our
country increasingly polarised it says
but labour has challenged so changed the
debate in British politics we've put the
public ownership that green industrial
revolution an end to austerity center
stage and introduce new ideas such as
plans for free broadband free personal
care
the Tories only offered more of the same
perhaps that's part of the problem
really that there were so many different
things in that list they didn't have
that defined central message that the
Conservatives had I'm sure there's going
to be a lot of soul-searching over there
you know was it lack of a definitive
message was it anti-semitism did that
play a part and the difficulty that the
leader having had to deal with that was
it their failure to really offer a
cohesive message on brexit all these
things actually if you think about it
just in the last week of the campaign
were things that their shadow health
sexually John Ashworth pointed out and
that unguarded conversation they said
they were having problems on the
doorstep he said it was dire I mean he
said he was joking when that was leaked
but he wasn't joking
it was clearly that was the problem that
they were having a with the leader B
with this issue around brexit and
there'll be a lot of questions being
asked tonight Jason Ferrell there live
for us in North London s Sophia Ridge
days well thank you both very much
indeed much more from them coming up
we're hoping to talk to the SNP in a
moment or two and John burka because so
we're focusing down on that result being
looking of course result I say the
prediction in the exit poll the
prediction the suggestion the Scottish
National Party could get 55 seats that
would be a huge result if it turns out
that way and as Beth was saying do you
think that would bolster the case for
another independence referendum it means
that the argument won't go away they
will press it with relentless force and
insistence and who can blame them on the
back of a result if this plays out that
is far better than most people
anticipated I mean it's a superb result
if they get 55 seats only one fewer than
in 2015 that's vastly superior to what
everybody was expecting people were
saying 45 46 there's an almighty rather
than in prospect isn't it between
Westminster and Holyrood if this is the
result then it sounds very clear he's
not going to let them have another
referendum and Westminster has to
legislate well it will be a case of the
irresistible force meeting the immovable
object
Dermott that's not a first in United
Kingdom politics but you're quite right
Boris Johnson has been absolutely clear
the Conservatives have no intention of
allowing another referendum on
independence and equally Nicola Sturgeon
has been resolution insistent
that is the right of the people of
Scotland so that's here from five would
be very well let's say let's see the
interpretation of the SNP themselves in
Holmes a use of joins me now from
Glasgow first of all overall reaction to
these numbers if it does turn out to be
the case fifty five seats for the SNP
that would be a very good result well
look at points to have very good night
for the SNP but let's state the obvious
this is an exit all not a result
whatever it's here also since Scotland
we have so many marginal seats something
seeks of course we 129 a 2017 with only
two votes some held by our opposition by
only a few tens of votes as well so
there's lots of local factors that play
here what I would see also is that it's
extraordinarily disheartening to see a
conservative majority clearly shows that
F the exit poll is true that Labour's
message and the rest of the UK clearly
hasn't cut through at all
well answer that point I was put into
John Berko for me from your perspective
how do you square that circle if Boris
Johnson the Conservatives are returned
with this huge majority we've heard all
along what Boris Johnson is said about
the prospect of another independence
referendum in Scotland they will he's
just basically said frankly said no it's
not going to happen how do you get round
that well very simply if your exit
pulled is true but actually in fact if
any of the polls that we've seen over
the recent months are true they point to
the SNP winning the election Scotland
and our message could not have been
clearer we stood on a very clear mandate
to stop Briggs it to let Scotland have
its own C interlock border so number 10
so independence was very much at the
front and centre of our campaign Boris
Johnson any UK government if they're
Democrats cannot deny the voice of the
Scottish people there's not for Boris
Johnson to dictate when there's another
independent referendum that is a choice
for the Scottish people and the Scottish
Parliament but every year that's the
moral authority the political authority
you you would claim if that is the
result but what about the political
reality the Westminster has to allow a
referendum to take place
well as I see as I keep saying I don't
think it's in the gift of the
Westminster Prime Minister of the
Westminster Parliament to dictate to
Scotland when they should have another
referendum particularly if the SNP as it
looks like not just from exit polling
but from all the polls that we've seen
thus far are likely to have a good night
and likely to be the winners in Scotland
so of course we'll have to discussion
the First Minister has made it clear
that she will rate to the Prime Minister
to demand that section 30 order it would
not be I think at all democratic for a
Westminster government be it Boris
Johnson anybody else to deny us that
mandate
well I say you know you've got you have
the numbers Boris Johnson will have the
numbers and we've got these positions
you're entrenched but something has to
give how does it give is it just you
making those arguments or could it go
beyond math person at the moment as we
see in First Minister could not have
been clearer at understand 2014 we had
the gold standard referendum we had an
agreement between two governments
Scottish nuclear government though
diametrically opposed their opinion on
independence but came together to find a
legal route towards that referendum we
want that gold standard applied for the
next referendum in 2020 and if a SNP
when then of course nobody can deny that
I gives us a further Mandy we already
have a mandate but a father mandate for
another referendum in 23 okay thank you
very much indeed if that all happens a
battle of wills is John Bercow has been
saying beside me perhaps in prospect
between Edinburgh and London well listen
while we're digesting this exit poll no
results of girls have been in yet at
election night counts right across the
country they are gathering in and
counting those votes and at some of them
counting them as quickly as they
possibly can as ever
we'll be watching to places especially
closely in the early parts of this
evening and these are the two cities
we've been reporting on an earlier
racing to be first Newcastle and
Sunderland
they vie to be the first to declare
their fingers a blur fair and those are
the people who'll tell us who's going to
win the race
Julian Joseph and Sarah Jane me let's go
to Gillian first
and how is it going there Gillian
hi Dermot well a lot busier than when we
last spoke a lot noisier the counting is
going ahead at a pace this of course is
a multi counter constituency were
looking at the constituencies of
Newcastle Central East and north and I
can see one of the candidates for
Newcastle Central qi4 we can just zoom
in on her there in the red dress she
retained the seat in 2017 had a majority
of her 15,000 24,000 in 71 votes and she
saw her share increased from 55% at the
2015 election to 65% in 2017
she is the first black MP for Newcastle
her monster Newcastle and father from
Nigeria her studied here as a dental
student and that's how her parents met
so took the seat in 2017 we also have
Nick Brown so I'm a little earlier on
not entirely sure where he is now he's
been a member of parliament the
newcastle upon tyne east since 1983 and
he served as Minister of Agriculture
Fisheries and food and also scre n't Lee
the Chief Whip we also have the other
Labour candidate took the seat in 2017
Catherine McKenna still on course at
Newcastle say to get that result in
sometime just after 11:00 so hopefully
we'll be back to you then and they will
have retained the crown for being the
fastest to declare we shall see well I
bet so thanks Julie and I bet some
wonder thinking very different yeah
let's go to Sarah Jane me there and how
far away do they think they are they're
in Sunderland Sarah Jane of course they
are thinking very differently here is
going well all 121 boxes from the three
constituencies are in the building and
being counted it's a real hive of
activities and you probably saw on your
screen little earlier those sixth
formers boys and girls running up and
down in this
get in there trainers they've got white
gloves on as well because it's wet
outside so they didn't want to drop any
of those boxes but all those boxes all
121 are now in the building and being
counted we spoke to the returning
officer Patrick Melia a little bit
earlier on and he said that he predicted
the first boxes would arrive in this
building at 10:03 I did hang on the
first box came in dead-on 1003 and
they've got a bit of an advantage the
Sports Hall we're standing in is at the
heart of the Horton and Sons of the
South constituency so that's a big
advantage remember the record to declare
here for Horton at Sunderland south is
1048 Patrick Melia though and his team
are saying that they're expecting the
first result a little after 11 p.m.
perhaps playing down expectations but
they're keen to stress that being
accurate is more important than being
1st but Dermot I can tell you've got a
bit of inside information we're hearing
rumors on social media and elsewhere
that it could be a third course in this
North East Derby Blythe
Valley that count going on there they
are very confident that they may be the
first to declare tonight so we're
predicting it around 11 p.m. to have the
first results here to stay with us for
that but keep an eye out for live valley
as well thanks for the tip sarah jane
live are we coming up on the outside
back with you both very soon Sarah Jane
Gillian thank you very much indeed well
listen our this exit poll predicting a
huge majority for the Conservatives
suggesting that might happen there
financial markets have been tracking
brexit all the ups and downs during the
course of the last year and in
particular what's going on on the money
markets it's taught say ed Conway about
that house the pound react in a sense
though there are kind of two polls
happening today on there we've got the
the election but then you've got the
market reaction to it you know we all
remember what happened after the last
election you know that big surprise on
the exit poll the pound fell very
sharply remember what happened on bricks
a day so on the EU fo and the pound fell
very sharply come and have a look at
what's happened to the pounds in the
wake of that exit poll so here we've got
a chance of it this is the pound versus
the dollar so that's stronger that's
weaker the pounding strong of the pound
win week
and this is the start of election day
and over the course of the start of the
day it was kind of trending a little bit
lower I think there were traders out
there who were a bit nervous about the
result and it could have went down from
about 1:30 - that's around there to
where it is there so just getting down
to about 131 but just look at this look
at what happens when the exit poll was
announced the pound skyrocketed it
absolutely took off and is up by about 3
cents to 135 it's actually gone up a
little bit since I made that choice it
is climbing very sharply indeed you know
this is a big surprise as we all do no
one was expecting quite as big a
majority as that a lot of people thought
there might well be even be a hung
parliament be why people were starting
to sell off the pound there but you know
this is a barometer for how investors
around the world are looking at the UK
you know often when the pound goes up
it's because people are putting money
into the country when it goes down it's
because they're taking it out well it
looks like people might be putting money
into the UK it looks like they've seen
this exit poll result and once a mess in
the again you know we can we can
speculate about why that might be they
might like the possibility of there
being more stability when it comes to
the rest of negotiations there might be
other things as well but nonetheless I
mean that's a pretty extraordinary
Chah you know the pound reacting very
sharply there'll be more reactions if
indeed that result is borne out or
indeed if it's if it's not right but
just consider that you know and very
different indeed to those results that
we had after the referendum and after
the last election where it fell it is
skyrocketing right now - that is
fascinating it thank you very much
indeed let's talk more about so this
exit poll and Beth Rigby well on the
exit poll two winners big winners
tonight the Conservatives in the
Scottish National Party - big losses the
Labour Party we've discussed then will
obviously go back to that but the
Liberal Democrats haven't the sexy
pulsing 13 now they had 12 at the start
of the last Parliament that would be a
gain of one seat yes and this was a
party you remember did so well in the
European elections positioned itself as
a remain a party thought it could eat in
to the labour vote Joe Swinson going
into this lecture she was the one that
facilitated the election actually labour
didn't really want it much but it was
Joe Swinson teaming up with the SNP that
got this December election over the
in the first place and she went into it
saying I could even be Prime Minister
she's come out the other end
potentially well there's a question mark
about whether she'll stay being an
embassy Stern botcher her seated or some
pleasure exactly there's four seats in
Scotland but on that exit poll are not
one haven't been won by the SNP now
twelve of those were conservative seats
she has won her seat back in 2017 she
lost it in 2015
could she have lost her seat don't know
yet I have to say though if she has held
on to her seat she was asked a number of
times if you really failed to perform in
this election as that looks like will
you resign and she said no I'm not gonna
stand down I mean what do you make of
that if the campaign strategy you know
if it's if this is the case it's a
repudiation of do you think people just
John Rico just kind of thought it was
going too far to say well outright
revoke article 50 without another
referendum sure answer that message yes
I think there have been two problems
with the Liberal Democrat campaign first
it was a strategic error to say we will
revoke article 50 the Lib Dems could
perfectly well have stuck to their
existing line that they would go for a
second referendum they chose to be a bit
more ambitious and to proceed beyond
that and I think that Gamble has
backfired that's the first point and I
think the second point really is that
they have just been subject to the
classic two-party squeeze the
Conservatives and labor have dominated
and are people of thought in the end
that really is the choice do you go
conservative would you go Labour and
under our existing electoral system we
thinly spread Lib Dem support it's very
different was the thing I'm you get many
sips of a squeeze bath I mean this was a
feature was a developing campaign there
was the squeeze but also if you look
back to 2010 and Clegg mania and the way
in which a Lib Dem leader managed to
kind of capture some sort of national
mood I think it's fair to say that Joe
Swenson surprised on the downside in
this election that unfortunately for her
the more the public saw of her the less
they like - I mean how do you think of
her as a performer in the Commons I mean
I think that's a really interesting
point because in some you're right Beth
Nick Clegg did catch
the attention and the imagination and
the support of very large numbers of
voters in 2010 and J Swenson clearly
hasn't done in the Commons in my
experience from the rather good vantage
point of the chair Joe Swenson is an
outstandingly good performer she's clear
she's strong she's articulate and as an
individual both in a group and
one-to-one she's very personable but it
was quite striking in this election that
according to the polling evidence the
more people saw her or heard her the
less they liked her now I'm not saying
that's fair in fact I don't think it is
fair I think she's an extremely good
person but she's fared badly in this
election okay not just in terms of our
party but personally well we're talking
about the Lib Dems Oh Lord Newby is here
from the Liberal Democrats going to talk
to you in just a moment or two Lord
doobie just wants to alert everyone to
the fact that we are waiting for results
from this race between Sunderland and
Newcastle to be the first to declare in
this general election of 2019 although
we're here whispers the perhaps Bligh
Valley is coming up on the outside of
that so we'll bring you those first
results as and when they come in in a
few minutes time we expect Lord Newby
you over reached in this campaign if
this exit poll is to be believed I don't
think we overreached we haven't done as
well as we thought Swensen could be
Prime Minister when we started the
election you recall that there were four
parties more or less in the twenties in
fact they were in the twenties what
happened is that Boris very cleverly
expropriated the brexit party by moving
to an extreme brexit position so they
collapsed to nothing we then found
ourselves with two issues on the
doorstep one was brexit and Boris got
all of those votes the the Tory vote
share is almost exactly because Bret she
didn't come out as a clear blue sky and
make it sound like you were blindside no
you formulated that policy of revoked
carefully you crafted it over many
months but the second point was that the
fear of Jeremy Corbyn was such that when
you talk to many many many conservatives
and said you are in favor of remain why
will will you vote for the Liberal
Democrats they said and I've been on
thousands of doors
they said we'd love to vote for you but
actually our fear of carbon trumps our
support for remain and that is what delt
as a very very big blow clear rule
analysis I mean if these numbers are to
be believed 13 seats we started the last
Parliament with with 12 that would be a
major major disappointment your overall
reaction well
our vote share will have gone up the
number of seats will have gone up our
view at the moment is that the position
in Scotland for us at least is rather
better than the poll suggests like
everybody we want a lot more votes and a
lot more seats we're going to get some
more votes and some more seeds at a time
when when the other party that's been
arguing on a remain platform has
completely collapsed we have not
completely collapsed we've moved forward
not as much as we'd wanted once in a
very long way one seat you ended I'm not
accepting for a minute I of course you
but tell me more about what you're
hearing from Scotland them because you
know that exit polls suggesting that the
leader Joseph Winston may be in a bit of
bomber well all I'm hearing from
Scotland is that the reaction we found
on the doorstep suggests that that exit
poll is rather over optimistic for the
SNP I don't have any absolutely detailed
figures from anywhere in Scotland but
that's what my Scottish colleagues are
telling me okay and tell me more about
this brexit strategy you talk there
about how the conservative squeezed the
brexit party vote you know people saying
who wanted remain who certainly wanted
another referendum why didn't you get
your act together with the Labour Party
they're gonna see so many seats this
evening with Lib Dem at labour
candidates getting thousands of votes
and the Conservatives sailing down the
middle well it was impossible for us in
advance of the election to reach an
agreement with the Labour Party because
what was their brexit policy it was all
over the place it was it was it was
renegotiate and not no commitment partly
that because the Lib Dems and because
juice Winston's went so aggressively up
against labour if it was framed as a
Breck solution was it seems to have been
that actually by going up against labour
use
lit the remain vote and you let the
Conservatives through the middle and
Boris Johnson's been rewarded with a
very very big majority that's going to
get a much harder brexit potentially
than the Lib Dems would have wanted so
wouldn't it have in hindsight might it
be better to have had a remain alliance
that was broader than just the smaller
parties well there was no prospects of a
remaining Alliance partly because the
Labour Party policy on brexit was very
unclear did you try did you approach
late there were lots of discussions with
labour in the run-up to the election
about brexit and about other things and
it was absolutely a thousand percent
clear but there was no deal to be done
and secondly we have made it clear in
the election that we could not support
Jeremy Corbyn as Prime Minister because
of his anticipate support or his lots of
problems according to the exit poll
that's a problem that's in the past John
Boyd I mean your new be describing there
this this two-party squeeze that you've
you've been describing and brexit seems
to have been there the vise that Boris
Johnson has used to squeeze them well I
think the Lib Dems have suffered from
that and I don't travel ups much of what
dick has said and of course he's
perfectly entitled to make the point
that it's early days and we don't know
whether the Lib Dems will do quite as
badly as has been foreshadowed but it is
a huge problem for them that they went
that much further on brexit than they
previously gone and I think the Reid's
something with an acknowledgement among
some Liberal Democrats that that was a
strategic error they could perfectly
well have stuck with the position to
which they've long been committed second
referendum second referendum second
referendum people's both people's both
people's both give the people the final
say
there was a sense stick I think that
going into an election and saying we
will revoke article 50 had a ring of the
anti-democratic about it at which a lot
of people took umbrage I think the
people the majority people took umbrage
were the people who were already having
taken umbrage with us
the interesting thing from the polling
shows that amongst remain voters revoke
was extremely popular
there were six million people signed a
petition for revoke and amongst labor
remain is the revoked policy was more
popular than Labour's own policy so
revoked was raised a lot but in my
experience it was largely raised by
people who work gonna vote for us anyway
and it was just an additional stick that
they saw to beat us with and so what
happens now if brexit is so-called
getting done by the Conservatives then
the battle moves on to what kind of
brexit it is that's right it's this
trade deal that has to be negotiated on
the conservative timetable and Boris
Johnson's timetable by the end of the
year now a lot of observers saying
including we're hearing from the
European Union that would have to be a
hard brexit how do you have you fight
against that
well Boris says a lot of things and he
tends not to stick to what he said so he
said that we've got to get the trade
deal done by the end of the year it
won't be done by the end of the year so
he will have a choice a difficult choice
either we crash out without a deal at
the end of the year or you extend the
period during which we remain in effect
members of the EU in terms of following
the rules now if I were a betting man
which I'm not I would say that Boris may
just change his view faced with the fact
that there is zero chance of getting an
acceptable trade deal by the end of the
day it seems to me that there's a very
reasonable point leaders with large
majorities have the luxury of choice yes
and is perfectly conceivable that Boris
Johnson could jump in one or other of
two directions he could stick to that
position of saying end of the year come
hell or high water we will leave and
whatever the deal is we're out in which
case it could well be on WTO extremely
hard brexit terms all he could bless
from his point of view with a munificent
majority say well actually I'm gonna
need a bit longer and in reality no
there will be a hardcore appeal would
have been really be saying well er gee I
don't need you European research group
you gave Teresa may so much trouble but
you know you're tiny now compared to
this majority yeah well it this is
interesting isn't it because Boris
Johnson predicated and built his his
base within the Conservative Party and
went on to win the leadership on the
back of ERG support support of the
brexit ears and that in turn developed
this quite hard-line brexit position but
you know he went into this election and
all through the campo say come on you're
not gonna be able to get your trade deal
done by twenty the end of 2020 so I will
absolutely be able to get it done and
you know why why did he want to do that
because he needs tears he might change
thank you very much Beth you are
watching the brexit election on Sky News
it is 11 o'clock let me take you through
the headlines so far and the exit poll
for Sky News the BBC and ITV News
predicts the Conservatives are on course
for a decisive win with 368 seats a
majority of 86 the exit poll also
suggests that Labour will secure around
191 seats that is their lowest number
would be their lowest number of seats
for many decades the shadow
international trade secretary Barry
Gardner has told Sky News that if that
exit poll is correct it will be
devastating and Boris Johnson was out
speaking to voters in Oxbridge tonight
just before the polls closed the pound
searched 2% after that exit poll
and in Scotland Nicola Sturgeon has
tweeted that it's a good night for the
Scottish National Party the exit poll is
predicting that the SNP will get around
55 seats well The Shadow Chancellor John
MacDonald lays in Westminster tonight
and joins me now what do you make of the
exit poll John MacDonald well if the if
the seats
if the seat tally comes out that way
it's going to be extremely disappointing
of course it is I'm not sure that seat
tally will shadow the completely the the
exit poll itself but even if it's
anywhere near that yes it is it's it's
really just extremely disappointing okay
and why is he disappointing I want to
put to you something your colleague
Barry Gardner said to me earlier he said
that we felt sorry for the voters that
they've been let down this is democracy
the voters have a clear choice in on
that exit poll they've decided they
don't like the Labour Party very much
and they want to go with Boris Johnson I
think I think the poll itself it looks
as though it was the brexit dominated a
lot of this I think was brexit fatigue
people just wanted it over and done with
and it put labour in a very difficult
position because the vast bulk of our
members supporter and campaign four
remain but large number of Labour MPs
including myself had constituencies that
voted leave so is what it was always
going to be difficult for us to straddle
those positions and that's what's hit us
pretty hard but I think basically it
looks as though all other debate on
other issues it's been squeezed out why
there's one issue prexy and as I say it
wasn't just levers I think I think also
even people in the referendum might have
voted remain at some point mr. Madan I
mean what I feel sorry for the voters
you'd be I'm sure you will be very
familiar with the term false
consciousness you know people took a
decision here not to vote for you and
yes get brexit done and they voted for
the Conservative Party why I felt sorry
for them because although they might
have voted to get brexit done it doesn't
look as though it will get done I think
it will go on for a number of years and
there are still those
No Deal brexit on the table as well so
it sounded simple as a slogan but in
practice and reality it's going to take
quite a while before anything does get
resolved that's the first thing I and I
fear also during that period we'll have
continuing uncertainty and I also fear
that the sort of deal that might well be
arrived at the end will not be
beneficial for the economy or protect
jobs and Livi's then so that's one issue
but also it is about installing what is
nothing is generally seen as possibly
the most right-wing extreme cabinet but
we've seen in our history and it means
therefore they will have if they have a
large majority like this they will have
then therefore the opportunity to
introduce some quite reactionary
policies and so there are there are
worries but I did that if the electorate
have decided this way that's democracy
and there you have to you have to
respect it but I don't are you accepting
I don't think I don't think it will
bring the country together I think
you'll be deeply divided still have you
spoken to the leader do you think you
should stay leader well obviously we
will wait and see what happens in the
morning with all the results coming out
and we'll see what whether the results
actually do match the exit poll itself
exit polls have been wrong in the past
but we'll see and then appropriate
decisions will be made I'm sure but you
know you've been on the campaign trail
for many make weeks now you've been up
and down the country you must be bracing
yourself to say goodbye to quite a few
colleagues tonight I if if the exit poll
is right and we lose that many copies I
feel for them I really do because I know
how hard they've worked in Parliament in
the interest of the country and I also
know how hard they've worked in their
own individual constituencies and if it
is anything on this scale we will have
lost some really good MPs and I I do
feel for them of course I do
and if mr. Corbyn you say you're going
to wait for the results to come in but
if he does go you need a new leader
you've been talked off as an interim one
well decisions will be made
appropriately in the right timescale
once we know the results I'm sure but
let me make it clear I'm not standing
for a leader of the Labour
I've said that time and time again
either as a temporary or as a permanent
that's not what I want to do what about
you personally even as Shadow Chancellor
you said in a magazine in TV you said
you would stand down if you lost and
lost this badly
no well as I say once we know the
results themselves that's the time to
make decisions and that that's what
we'll do in the meantime let's watch
these results and I'm hoping that the
seats share will not be as okay
dramatically bad as the poll itself and
I don't think they will but as I say
it's okay Charlotte Chancellor thank you
very much indeed for talking just so
maybe catch up with you when those
results do come in this is the exit poll
I want to talk you through again that I
was discussing there with John McDonnell
the Shadow Chancellor looking very very
bad indeed an indication from this exit
poll talked to thousands of people who
had voted up and down the country during
the course of the day saying that labor
might get a hundred and ninety-one seats
that would be its lowest number of seats
since 1935 underperforming even Michael
foot in 1983 the Conservatives you can
see there let's say just bring it back
up so we can absorb that I was talking
about labor because we've just been
talking to John McDonnell but I just
want to show you what the exit poll is
saying that the Conservatives might get
we don't seem to be able to bring it to
you can see it at the bottom of your
screen 368 a majority of 86 and that's
the introduction to the foreign
secretary Dominick Rob who's joined me
now you're looking calm but underneath
it there a bit of a smile I mean you you
must be Sparkle smiling in conservative
HQ tonight I think look it's an exit
poll we'll wait and see what the in
pretty accurate in the past I'm not
gonna push back to violently with you
but look the reality is let's see both
the scale but also the shape of
award-earning majority would look like
the most important thing for us is that
we wanted to end the uncertainty of
Parliament get the a functioning
workable majority so the government can
take the country forward on breaks it
but also on the other areas that would
unleash the potential of the country on
in a moment yeah you know at least that
there HS their priorities I think that
positive message
and the choice between that and the
uncertain in the prowl thankfully the
negative we don't want to rerun the
campaign okay but that's what we do want
to what we do want to talk what what
happens next if this is the case but
just on that exit poll you be aware you
are the candidate of course in your own
CD Sharon Walton that's been the
concerted campaign to get you out so
remain voting seats what are you hearing
what are you feeling well look we'll
wait and see
well the exit poll says you might be
okay it says we might be okay and that's
our feeling too but let's wait and see I
always think if you've been campaigning
five weeks show the electorate a bit of
respect and have some humility as a
candidate but the right way throughout
there's been a pretty positive feedback
for us so we're feeling you've been very
frank with us Tommy what you worried at
times during the campaign you you read
the papers you read your own polling I
mean they must have got pretty close
well we'll see but why are you worried
you're they're insane so not really and
I'll tell you why there's two debates
and two theaters for most general
elections there's the media theater and
the punditry and social media and all
that and then there's the steady
feedback you get the quiet moments with
swing voters on the doorsteps and I may
be proved wrong but we felt confident
about the positive feedback for our paws
and I know you're up and down the
country were you surprised then in other
parts of the United Kingdom particularly
in England well there never been
Conservative MPs and not for many many
decades were you surprised at some of
the reactions you were getting some of
the feedback you were getting
particularly from labour voters so it's
very striking I was up in Wolverhampton
I was up in Warrington and we're clearly
getting a hearing in homes across the
country that we hadn't done for some
time and part of that was about brexit
part of it was I think the sense of
positivity the the Prime Minister and
the Conservatives have offered I think
we've got some great candidates across
the country and let's face it part of it
is about wanting to break through the
uncertainty and a lot of those
working-class voters not liking the
offer from court and that is the very
point how do you serve them now as a
Conservative government how do you serve
them personally representing if it does
turn out to be the case leave three Asia
and Walton which is high up the economic
scale how do you serve these different
voters who have lent you perhaps for the
time being their vote you know want to
see want to be convinced that they
should stay with you how do you do that
those two things I think assuming the
exit policies corroborated by the seat
by seat vote share then look having an
alliance between the aspirational
working on middle classes is the glue
that I think shapes Tory victories in
election campaigns now you mentioned my
seat compared to say Warrington Oliver
Hampton
actually although there are very
affluent parts of my constituency I was
out tonight in lower green one of the
less affluent areas and I was interested
in of course its did for different
reasons but actually in in many seats
you will have obviously two more or less
degrees that mix of voters so we you
know but what's really important for the
Conservatives I think is to make sure we
cement that Alliance and deliver because
that's what they want to hear let's
bring in a man you know very well indeed
cross swords with him Adela if you heard
the lash of his tongue while he was
presiding over you pretty well behind
was he was he where they were pretty
well backed and Dominic was extremely
well I'm failing ly courteous certainly
to the chair and frankly to the house I
think there was one [ __ ] up on one
occasion a statement wasn't really long
time that was rather embarrassing it
wasn't his personal fault though he had
to take responsibility but no Dominic
was always unfair okay well there's his
report card serious stuff because John
you been making this point throughout
the evening that this idea of getting
brexit done in the Foreign Secretary
referring to that there get it done and
then move on you were saying when you
don't really move on because it's only
with the withdrawal agreement
yes that's my point look I'm not
knocking the central proposition here
that if the Conservatives have got a big
victory they will get the first part of
brexit done in pretty short order that
is not in dispute I'm not arguing that
what I'm saying is that there are
certain facts that don't change and
those include the need to negotiate a
trade arrangement with the European
Union and the need to negotiate trade
arrangements for the United States and
the rest of world that's before you even
consider the security partnership the
fight against climate change the action
of a collaborative kind that is needed
to tackle the
of human trafficking and a vast
miscellany of other issues to those will
take time and they don't depend only
yeah depend on what other countries
think as well and that will take you so
any point I'm making it's a very very
important point if you want to move on
if you get mired then in these
negotiations with the European Union
Michel Barnier saying the other day
eleven months not a chance you know we
looked at the renegotiation for instance
of the NAFTA deal United States Mexico
and Canada I mean it's a much looser
arrangement it's taken them three years
to do that now can you really do it in
11 months so there's two or three things
there first of all one of the reasons
that it took so long to negotiate the
original brexit deal was because we had
out in Parliament if we've got them a
kind of majority this is suggested this
will very much strengthen and reinforce
our position in Phase two but also we've
now got the future relationship at least
a map of it in the form of a wish list
there's another political declaration
it's the political declarations is
equivalent for lawyers would the heads
of terms agreed with the other side and
Phil Hogan the Trade Commissioner has
said that it's eminently doable and I
think it's very interesting the mood
coming out of Brussels this evening
which is actually a clear direction of
travel and that will make it easier for
them because they'll feel like they've
got a partner
which is a bit more predictable and now
that's certainly going to be true if
these figures are born out but the truth
is isn't it mr. OTT that if you want to
and you get that bigger majority you
have got the latitude to delay brexit
extend the transition if you need to
because if you do want to have a
five-year term in which you do appeal to
this much broader electorate you
probably need to do a bit more in tax
and spend as well because you might need
to have a sort of broader welfare state
offer and in that case you probably need
a really good deal don't you with the EU
for the economy we do want a good deal
we want to get cracking on it and we
want to lift the shadows and the clouds
of uncertainty and I think we're in a
much better position with a stronger
majority and as to for the other stuff
these aren't either ORS and truth is
actually what the Prime Minister's
offered we have had a heavy emphasis on
investing in public services we've
talked in the Sajid Javid has talked
about
for a decade of recovery after the
recession the financial crash now having
a decade of renewal so I agree with you
but I think both of those things should
be done at the same time last question
foreign secretary well you mentioned
Sajid Javid the prime minister Sarah
he's going to stay in his job if there's
a reshuffle do you get any similar
reassurances I wouldn't dream of
creating or prejudicing the decisions of
the boss such a message modesty and
would you like to remain as far as I you
know first every reshuffle I say the
same thing I think I think it's really
important that the head of a team
particularly the head of a government
has the total free hand pick the team
they need but there's no doubt there is
going to be a reshuffle well they'd have
to be because there'll be some people
who have stepped down and they've been
people you know it would be like the top
Joe and Nicky Morgan so I think there'll
be some changes but look that is the
property Philip Anderson DOMA can I just
ask Dominic because he's a very very
clever bloke how long do you reckon the
trade negotiation with the United States
will take well they of course got an
election coming up so I think it I think
there is an opportunity before that and
we want to give it a good go what are
those pigs I see flying in front of my
very eyes you know I tell you what I
tell you this Mike Pompeo who's the US
Secretary of State said to me we are
ready pen in hand to do a deal once
you've left the EU so one of the things
that this will have a knock-on effect is
I think are lining up of those countries
that wanted to see which way the wind
was going on brexit because that will
affect the trade negotiations so not
only if this is borne out as we say
again not only it's as good news for
delivering brakes it will be good news
for the wider global Britain agenda
which is sending the Foreign Office
we're very keen on well mr. Robert thank
you very much indeed though we'll let
you go off to your count I mean there's
a small amount of remaining as an MP
before you find out if you stay on as
foreign secretary or don't it Rob thank
you very much indeed we are waiting we
are hearing it's come out fairly soon
the first official results in this
general election campaign we are keeping
a hawk-like eye on both these counts in
Newcastle and Sunderland
and were first to declare right up to
the last general election Newcastle
nicked that crown away from them and
those two great cities are now vying
between each other to be first to
declare their MP for the new Parliament
it's also going to be fascinating to see
okay maybe only two results but these
are strong strong labour areas in the
past and if the exit poll is to be
believed well then we are expecting the
Conservatives to perform very well in
areas like the Northeast so even if
there is a a Labour MP returned in those
declarations we're going to take a very
close look at the numbers in there there
the change in the share of the vote to
see if the Conservatives are showing
signs of making headway as set as deep
into labour territory as Newcastle and
Sunderland and on that very note let's
talk more about - what the exit poll is
suggesting for us my colleague Edie
Conway is gonna talk us through the
numbers and what it all means
Edie yeah thanks Toby and obviously
interrupt me if we do get a result from
either new costless Sunderland will
waiting for those numbers but it's let's
have a look at the exit poll them what
it's suggesting in short this looks like
it's going to be an excellent night for
the Conservative Party if the exit poll
is right Boris Johnson could win 368
seats we'll give them a majority
government 86 I believe it takes let's
have a look though how that actually
plays out in our government builder you
can take those these are kind of virtual
seats in the House of Commons so the
left side you have the government
benches let's add on the Conservatives
put them there on the government benches
and there we have it there over that
line of 326 seats giving them that
majority 86 majority and our exit polls
suggest actually look on the right-hand
side those are the opposition benches
there you can see their labour if they
get 191 seats of the exit polls suggest
well look how far they are from that
line an extraordinary potential result
now we're going to be keeping our eyes
on the results as they come through from
across the country about number of seats
that the parties are getting you can see
that up there that's the the big
dashboard there with those numbers and
let's fly past that and you can see this
hexagon map
of the UK that is it here in sky HQ we
will be coloring that in with every
constituency as they come in tonight
perhaps starting in the next few minutes
and it looks like it might well keeper
that Labour might well actually be able
to keep Kensington we'll have a look
actually because they've got a number of
those seats and we do want to take a
little closer let's get rid of those
boards and we'll bring on a few of the
interesting seats that we're going to be
looking at at least start with Don
Valley we potentially now Caroline Flint
is in place there and that might well be
one of those seats we've been looking
through the numbers on the exit poll
that might well be one of those seats
which could eventually go to the
Conservatives so Caroline Flint there in
Don Valley again you know these are
seats which a lot of people thought were
part of that labor red wall that would
be their defense that were in sure that
they wouldn't necessarily lose well Don
Valley might well be one of the seats
that might go tonight let's have a look
through as well around the country
I mentioned Kensington a moment ago it's
going to be a really interesting race
there and you can see there that was a
seat which labour gained from the
Conservatives by just twenty votes in
2017 so incredibly narrow majority
they're beating off competition from
former Tory MP Sam kima who's standing
for the Lib Dems and the exit poll
actually suggesting that it might well
be a good showing for labour in the
capital so there you have labour doing
actually quite well in the capital
labour doing well in cities not so well
in towns that's one of those stories
we've seen as the the map of Britain has
been changed we'll have much more about
how that's changing over the course of
the next few hours and east on bond
embossing sure what about Scotland in
general I mean but let's look at the Lib
Dem leader Joe Swenson standing in
eastern Barton sure the exit poll
suggests her chances of losing her seat
at the moment are about 50/50 it's about
as narrow it's it could possibly get for
Joe Switzer I mean what an extraordinary
story that would be for the Lib Dems
potentially to lose their leader tonight
and the SNP who would be potentially
winning that seat if they if they get on
the other right side of that 50/50
potentially with 55 seats Accord
the exit poll that's within the whisker
of their highest ever and if you look
across Scotland it would leave only four
only for non SMP C's looks like it's to
Tory at one live Devon one labour I mean
extraordinary numbers let's see if those
are borne out by the numbers that we get
through from the results exactly at it
is going to be a quite extraordinary
night if those exit poll results matched
by the results that are coming in just
to alert you were expecting two or three
very soon from the northeast from
Newcastle and Sunderland maybe blyve
Valley as well while we're awaiting
those so want to look at the picture in
some more detail what the exit poll has
been telling us particularly about the
Northeast and our deputy political
editor Sam Coetzer is behind me
crunching through some of those numbers
Sam thank you Dermot yes we're about to
get Sunderland and Newcastle in the next
few minutes so here's why the Northeast
is particularly useful to provide clues
for how election nights are going to go
this is a Labour Heartland in 2017
something like 26 of the 29 seats in the
region actually went labour but it was
also a place that saw the only place in
the country the only region in the
country to actually see a swing to the
Conservatives it is also a region that
voted dramatically for leave in 2016 so
this has been a kind of crucible a test
case for the Conservatives these are
exactly the seats in the Northeast some
of these seats are exactly the ones that
they've been trying to take now the ones
that you're gonna see first probably
have labour majorities so big in
Newcastle and Sunderland that the
incumbents will keep them but here's
what to watch for if the exit poll is
right that you should see a reduction in
the Labour vote share according to the
exit poll it's likely across the
Northeast that you might see a swing
from Labour to the Conservatives of five
maybe even six percent that could give
the Conservatives five or six games in
the northeast places like not only
bishop or theater Auckland Darlington
Sedgefield possibly even Blythe Valley
so a number of places there where you
could see the concert and you
could see conservative gains Blythe
Valley for instance you're just hearing
we're just hearing there's a recount
there so clearly that seat is too close
to cool if I look at my sheet that
requires something like a nine point
three percent gay
swing from the Labour Party to conserves
an extraordinary swing to win there so
we're going to be looking at these early
results about just how much the labor
vote Falls and the conservative vote
Rises okay Sam thank you very much
indeed for that hearing that recount in
Blythe Valley they were thought of us
perhaps potentially are going to be
amongst the frontrunners to declare
first in this general election
presumably out of the race there if
they're going through a recount but of
course then it's down to the two
favorites Sunderland and you cast away
hearing four or five minutes away and
one of them anyway
Sunderland Sarah Jamie is there how
close do they think they are I would
tell my I've just been given a five
minute warnings we're on standby for the
first results to be delivered it's
around what is it twenty four minutes
past eleven they declared it around five
past eleven the first result from Horton
and Sunderland South in the last general
election so it's a bit slower
is that because turnout has been higher
we don't yet know obviously we'll find
out more when the results are announced
but quite a few of those counting the
votes have been sitting still for quite
some time
I've been understanding that and people
be getting texts from those at the live
valley counts are saying that they were
ahead but as you've been saying they're
having a recount there so something's
still hopeful of getting the first
results to be declared but obviously
they are saying that being accurate is
more important I'm just hearing that
hearing sums of them there's been a 58
okay so genom come true coming up on the
rails sorry so Jane over to Gillian in
Newcastle what's happening
yes Islands has fallen we believe that
we're about to declare here we haven't
had an official declaration of that but
we were warned that it could be any time
when we can see Pat Ritchie going up to
make the declaration the returning
officer it will be for Newcastle Central
we're told and they were first in 2017 a
lot later than they were at that time
one minute past 11:00 and we're now
11:25 p.m. can I have your attention
please
I'm ready to declare the result for
Newcastle upon Tyne Central I Pat
Ritchie hereby give notice that the
total number of votes for each candidate
for the newcastle upon tyne central
constituency is as follows Syed Ali Ave
also known as Ali RA 2709 mark mark
Frederic Glenn Griffin
grexit party 2542
Chan yellow Susan inverter also known as
Chi inverter 20 1560
Emily Victoria Payne the Conservative
candidate 9290 team our Jim Pittman also
known as T Pittman 1365 and that she and
woulda has been Julie elected to serve
as member for said constituency
the result Xian were re-elected to the
Newcastle Central constituency as with
meterics that contain obviously to start
by thanking the returning officer for
her excellent work and also the police
who have maintained our safety and
security and the amazing teams of
Newcastle employees here and also in all
the polling stations across Newcastle
who have done such fantastic work to get
us here and I believe I am the own I am
the first MP to be declared that right
so for the moment the entire British
Parliament is well trailing in second
but not too far behind the result coming
in from Sunderland sarah-jane
returning officer hereby given orders
for each candidate for the Horton and
Sunland South constituency is as follows
Richard Peter Bradley Green Party 1125
Paul Edgeworth Liberal Democrat 2319
Richard Elvin you Kip 897 Christopher
John Charles Howarth the Conservative
Party 13,000 195 Norma
Bridget moved philipson Labour Party
16200 attack
Kevin Lawrence you'll brexit party 6000
165 and that Bridget me if philipson has
been duly elected to serve as member for
the said constituency
I'd like to invite the electric kinda
decision
it is privileged well there you have it
the result in for Horton and sunder them
South it is a labor win for Bridget
Phillips and he's just making her
acceptance speech behind me she got
sixteen thousand two hundred and ten
votes a much tighter race this time
around and a much smaller majority a
majority of 3115 so a much tighter
majority than last time the majority in
the last lecture was twelve thousand
three hundred and thirty one so that was
shrunk quite significantly but it is
still a labor win for Horton and
Sunderland south this evening we're
still waiting for Sunderland Central and
Washington and some of the West or bring
you those results Dermot as soon as they
come in Sarah Jane thank you very much
indeed and thanks to Jillian in
Newcastle we want to go through both
these results there yes are the early
declare is just for the record Newcastle
just beat happen in Sunderland South but
some pretty astonishing numbers coming
out here let's stay with Hammond
Sunderland south and look at that
majority yes Bridget Phillips and his
back and making her acceptance speech
there as the continuing Labour MP for
lis constituency on a share of 40%
Conservatives on 32 the brexit party on
15 and look at this this is perhaps
going to tell us the tale of the evening
labor way down in that share that
majority then shaved down is Sarah Jane
the same from 12 to three thousand
eighteen point seven nearly 19 percent
down the Conservatives up slightly the
brexit party they're putting on 15 and a
half gaining 15 and a half percent of
course they didn't stand in the last
election the Lib Dems up a smidge as are
the greens and this arguments by Boris
Johnson that he was putting just on the
eve of the election and of course says
many conservative supporters was saying
to the brexit party now you remember
that the brexit party leader Nigel
Farage
said that they would not stand against
conservatives but they did stand in the
main some kind of its pulled out they
did stand in the main against labour
candidates the argument by Boris Johnson
was that you will still split the brexit
vote these could become could you
imagine happening Sunderland South
becoming a conservative seat well
without the brexit party that might have
happened and we had recounting Bligh
Valley was staying in the northeast
rock-solid labour seat for so many years
let's have a look at it live Alan just
just hearing running in there third they
were close to declaring this is this is
by the by now we're hearing a ten-point
swing to the Conservative Party from the
Labour Party the brexit party they're on
3390 one but it's those top two we need
to look at seventy thousand four hundred
forty Labour pushed down to sixteen
thousand seven hundred and twenty eight
Ian levy elected with a slim majority
they don't mind about that those
conservatives Blythe Valley John boko's
we talk through this look at that the
conservative vote chair going up to
forty two point seven percent up five
point four percent the Labour Party
going down there fifteen percent the
brexit party up 8.3% of the same Boris
Johnson's warning was that you'll take
seats away from conservative candidates
well perhaps they're also taking seats
away from labour candidates but just
that that thought that here we are
this confirming very early on I know but
the direction of this exit poll if they
take some seats like this yes it's empty
does I mean there are two catastrophic
results for the low body there first of
course in Blyth Valley
Ronnie Hamel has represented that seat
as the Labour Member of Parliament for
about three decades he's retired there's
a new neighbor Canada but it is a
staggering result that Labour's vote
share so far down and that there is a
Conservative MP for Blythe honey if you
look at Houghton and Sunderland there's
never been a consensus never be no
conserve there'd be four live on Ian
Houghton and Sunderland South were
Bridget philipson has been reelected
three-quarters of her majority has
evaporated he's gone down from over
12,000 to only just over three thousand
so those are hugely negative results for
labour
it's quite interesting to juxtapose them
against the result in Newcastle for
Cheon whooaaa and Cheon whereas majority
was reduced but by nothing like as big a
much related to through the prism of
brexit I mean the prism
that was a city that voted you now enter
merrily to remain Sunderland heavily to
leave and there's an obvious link
between the brexit instinct on the one
hand and help okay better agree we're
already dealing with three results but
look where they are and two of them as
John Burke are saying catastrophic for
labour
they've held on there with Bridget
Phillips yes and I spoke to I spoke to a
Labour candidate in one of these red
wall seats if you like these seats
stretching from Wales across to
Humberside where the Tories are
targeting vote leave areas and this
candidate said to me that they thought
that these seats could go and it would
be a matter of few hundred votes and a
number of seats and look at that they've
gone from a Labour majority of 8,000 in
Blyth Valley and it's gone conservative
by just seven hundred and twelve votes
that is extraordinary isn't it did you
tell me percent swing but Beth I mean
while you were on the road during the
campaign did you get that sense of just
how deeply this get brexit down slogan
was resonating with these with a lot of
labour voters I did and there was that
that was a theme running through many of
the visits that I I went on up into the
Midlands and up into parts of the north
that get brexit done was very powerful
but I have to say as well it wasn't just
get 4x it down it was the leader
it was the leader and actually we're
talking a lot about Boris Johnson's
great strategy he was also very lucky to
have been up against an opponent that
was actually a great asset for Boris
Johnson because of the problems that
Jeremy Corbyn was finding amongst many
traditional labor voters they just
didn't like him very much
hmm but why didn't it work last time
around for Theresa May was that I think
there was a couple of things I think
that I think that the whole Rexach
gridlock wasn't as embedded two years
ago I think things have changed people
genuinely really fed up and also Teresa
may had a bad campaign but thirdly
Jeremy Corbyn was an unknown in 27 years
there was a Corp in search because
people didn't know him they'd read a lot
of negative things about it they saw
them they quite liked him he was he was
priced in in this selection and there
wasn't a kind of upside of who is Jeremy
Corbyn they they knew what Jeremy Corbyn
was like two years down the line from
2017 and just decide that they didn't
want him to be primary ok well it's in
plenty core to discuss on that obviously
but so we want to talk through some
numbers as I say only three results but
in these labour heartlands former labour
Heartland in the case of blind valley
Sam Coates has been telling we were
musing Sam about whether these results
are going in the direction of the exit
poll it seems so yes bluntly Dermot the
answer to that question is yes it does
appear as if there's nothing in the
early results that would suggest that
the exit poll is in any way out of line
indeed the early results suggest that
the Conservatives could win four seats
in the Northeast region Bishop Auckland
is also therefore under threat from the
Tories Darlington Sedgefield and
Stockton South now all really looking in
danger you can see that after these
swings that we've seen if you look at
that result in Blyth Valley the first
gain for the Conservatives of the
evening you've got about a 10 percent
swing from the Labour Party to the
Conservatives that's a huge swing which
is why quite so many votes and quite
quite quite so many seats in this region
do seem to be going across into the blue
column you've also got a notable number
of brexit party votes over 3,000 of them
or 8% but the stunning feature in the
blithe rally seats and frankly in all of
the seats in the Northeast so far is the
decline in the labor share of the vote
one other thing that's been borne out
from the early exit poll is that the
labor vote seems to be going further
down in in leave areas than remain areas
the to leave voting seats that we've
seen and blood valley is 60%
leave have been much more dramatic than
those in the remain seat of newcastle
upon tyne okay Sam fascinating we
haven't got much to deal with in terms
of hard and fast results but they're
certainly going as Sam was saying there
in the direction of the exit poll well
plenty more seats to declare a 647 to be
precise but want to talk Lea as Sam was
saying there one of the features of
what's gone on there in Newcastle
Sunderland and and Blythe Valley is the
performance of the brexit party and you
remember just got to remind you that the
brexit party stood in seats where there
were Labour MPs from the last Parliament
not against the Conservatives got so
Jake Pugh with me era brexit Party MEP
first of all your reaction to those
pretty good performances there in the
northeast about your party it's
fantastic isn't it and seeing where the
vote is coming from and so I think in
Newcastle labour were down seven we were
up seven very strong performance by mark
here that's the difference and taking
the vote from Labour absolutely
validates the strategy but don't can I
just say a couple of things first okay
isn't it isn't it the day when the
people speak isn't it just absolutely
fantastic and also I know it's just a
poll but absolutely we should be
congratulating the Conservative Party if
this is what has happened and lastly if
I just may say yeah you're an incredible
night for the regatta brexit air
community I've got to ask you I mean you
do you seem pretty happy but obviously
obviously a lot of votes but we're
first-past-the-post system and and all
that goes with that but um you got your
chairman standing in Hartlepool also in
the northeast they're looking at the
count there you got high hopes you might
actually get a seat in parliament of
course of course we hope to win seats of
course we do
but I think we've been able to shift the
agenda so extraordinary at the end of
March where we were then to where we are
now
Theresa May left withdraw the bill
failed twice clean brexit nobody had
ever mentioned clean brexit that move to
stage which we can discuss further down
the line what kind of brexit the Boris
Johnson might go for if he does get a
majority like that well you seem a bit
out of kilter with your leader Nigel
Feroz says well you know that's why he
was saying you know they need to be kept
on the straight and narrow they the
Conservatives under Boris Johnson will
not deliver brexit this withdrawal
agreement is not brexit in Nigel
Ferraris terminology you just said there
we
we'll get brexit done we will be leaving
I didn't I said we will be leaving I
didn't say that done okay I said we will
be lignite affright except that he says
it's gonna be brexit in name a
transition I didn't use that expression
I said we will be leaving the European
Union on the 31st day Jan into
translation that is something that is
very very exciting we said we were hard
to be fired
to answer your question are the
deficiencies in the withdrawal agreement
and the political declaration yes we are
now it's going to be interesting to see
because the Prime Minister if the poles
deliver and he has a strong majority he
then has two choices does he then tack
back to the center that's one option or
does he turn round to the EU and say
right we have a negotiated withdrawal
agreement we commit to that but let's
now negotiate the free trade agreement
and sign the two off together so go
right back to the very first point where
the UK made the mistake on the
sequencing new Parliament who cannot
bind the previous I'm not so that is
absolutely a perfectly real so he might
go one way you might tack back to the
center a softer brexit or he might say
new Parliament will stick with the
withdrawal agreement but will sign the
two documents okay it's clearly in a
state of paranoid anxiety at this point
for the very simple reason that we
flagged up earlier that there is this
choice a choice between pivoting to the
right or pivoting to the center and that
is the luxury that the Prime Minister if
he has the strongest majority actually
can indulge he confused he can go Center
which will infuriate the brexit party or
he can go far out to the right and I
okay keep the seek hard brexit and of
course vexillology would love that known
as we serve the interest portion that's
all I want to do because some we want
more a result set give us more grist to
our mill statistics and we be looking at
the northeast Swindon north is due to
declare shortly it's a leave leaning
seat early voting seat in the referendum
in 2016 Swindon North is pretty solidly
conservative so we are waiting to see
changing share of the votes is going to
be fascinating see if it works down
there in Swindon as well as it has in
the Northeast but but J Pugh your point
is you just don't know don't you I mean
with if Boris Johnson does get a
majority like that is John Bercow is
saying well as we've been saying earlier
it was the the ERG in his own party who
were pushing let's let me turn it hard
brexit pushing him closer and closer to
that the WTO the clean brexit let's
let's call it that he's now in a
position if he wants for instance to
extend the transition period even bring
back what the backstop well yeah
extending the transition period would be
a strange place to go I think for
anybody I mean the we've heard it so
many times
get brexit done interesting they've
dropped the oven ready in the last few
days because everybody got bored with
that that clearly didn't work in the
focus groups but absolutely they have
almost but I would have thought
extending is not really gonna fit with
where they are even it is negotiating an
FTA a complicated process of course okay
Johnson has that sort of majority he
absolutely can extend he can do what he
wants and ironically it could end up
couldn't it that we are negotiated for
longer in order for him to try and get
as good a trade deal as he can because
he'll have one eye on the economy and
probably a tax-and-spend program to try
and keep all these seats it looks like
he's gonna win it then absolutely all
those are all those options are open of
course there goes I suppose the question
that jake has to ask himself and answer
for himself is this but you put it - it
does Boris Johnson feel as passionately
about having a complete clean hard break
from the EU as the brexit party does now
many people would say that what Boris is
absolutely passionate about is Boris
becoming and remaining prime minister
and holding power and wielding and doing
what he thinks at the time at any
particular time is right he doesn't have
necessarily that ideological could I've
got to put that back either you say many
people John bears one of those who knows
the other Boris Johnson so well I've
always thought that Boris Johnson is a
kind of
ralien figure in the sense that he
thinks first and foremost that politics
is about the acquisition and retention
of power he travels relatively light
ideologically and we all know that
historically he's had different
positions on the european union i don't
say that rudely i simply say that as a
statement of fact he doesn't have that
ideological rigor or dare I say
fanaticism which characterizes the
brexit party that is something I think
that is going to cause mr. Pugh much
loss of sleep in the weeks months and
years ahead
well it certainly won't cause Menelaus
to sleep the answer that you posed the
question about Boris Johnson's character
clearly John you know him better than
anybody else on the on this panel but
III think he has multiple options open
to him to say that it is fanatical to
wish to leave all the institutions of
the European Union to not have a treaty
under which you're bound by the rule of
the ECJ and there's an independent
arbitration committee that always has to
look to the ECJ for the decision if you
think that is fanatical then of course
that you're in touch okay but time I
hope you don't see that as phonetic
thank you thank you very much indeed a
very interesting gentleman Jake Pugh
thank you very much indeed JP from the
brexit party want to talk about the Lib
Dems
and Scotland now rolled up in one we are
going to talk to Christine Jardine in a
moment or two just to allow you we've
told you already we're expecting our
fourth declaration so far this evening
gonna be a very long evening could be a
very long evening indeed for the Labour
Party if the exit poll is to be believe
the declaration expected there and
Swindon North fairly shortly I mentioned
they're going to Edinburgh to talk to
Christine Jardine for the Liberal
Democrats and a very good evening to you
Christine Jardine and May first of all
ask you on the back of our exit poll
just personally it's suggesting you may
be in quite a lot of trouble holding on
to your seat I'm I don't know
the exit pool is seeing that Google lose
seats but you know it gives a good
national picture but it doesn't drill
down into the individual seats and I
think we need to look at that more
closely we have a lot of marginal seats
particularly in Scotland there's not the
same coverage for pools there is don't
so so I think we'll see as the evening
goes on if the pool is correct but I
think it's too early at the moment to be
absolutely sure everybody we're all a
little surprised because it doesn't
reflect what we've been getting on the
doors so we'll have to see whether the
picture that we've been getting on the
doors is right or whether the poll is
right and okay no it's too early to say
can't deny that but what we can discuss
is you mentioned being on the doors what
kind of Christian Johnnie we will come
back to you if we can that's okay if you
if you can hang on we're getting a
declaration I'm told in Swindon off no
we see movement and we jump on it as I
say we're watching all these early
counts as closely as we possibly can did
I sound a bit like you there John Burke
oh I know yes well we understated reader
anticipation that it's going to be
fascinating even Christine Jardine we we
can come back to you
just it's what you were hearing on the
doors did this revoke article 50
argument I mean didn't people say to you
that's that's going a bit far I'm you
know may say well I am a remainer but I
think this should at least be another
referendum actually and what the you go
pool tells us is that it was popular
amongst Gimenez it was six there was 67
percent approval rate for it so it's you
know if people want to remain in the
European Union he liked that line Anna I
think it's over simplifying to say that
that line particularly was unpopular and
I think we'll have to wait and see and
after the election and we have all the
votes counted then we will have a proper
picture and we'll see which seats have
done better than others and which way
the marginal seats which made legal
because there are lots of seats which
even the the exit poll is saying too
close to call so we'll just have to wait
and see okay well and talk to me about
the campaign in Scotland of course it
was termed the brexit election but there
was a big dollop of endear f to throw
them in there as well wasn't they did
that make it doubly difficult for the
Liberal Democrats no we had a lot of
support for our anti independence stance
because let's remember we don't know yet
how the votes will break down this time
but in 2017 the SMP had nine hundred and
seventy seven thousand votes I think and
there was one point six million people
voted for the for once mo bettah Sam
unionist parties so well you know we
have to wait and see tonight what
happens and we saw in the summer
that's the SMP threw everything they had
at the Scottish parliamentary
by-election in Holyrood with the
actually spent more than they had done
and the entire remain referendum
campaign and they did win the Scottish
by-election
so you know it's quite difficult to see
where this this pool result tonight has
come from and I think we will see clear
later in the evening for at the moment
it's too sensitive okay with almost
caveats we've had precious few results
so far but if it is you know round about
13 seats this exit poll prediction for
the Liberal Democrats even two three
four five more it's not really a
vindication of the strategy and not
really an endorsement of your leader is
it do you think you might have to look
at that know what we've seen in this
campaign is the Labour Party a
disastrous campaign from the liver party
but the Labour Party in the Conservative
Party almost sort of contrived to keep
anybody else out of it to squeeze
everybody else out the debate Boris
Johnson not turning up for interviews
and the lack of scrutiny which is
important to any democracy and seeing
the variety of voices heating all the
opinions
that to me is what's fundamental to
having same democracy and I think they
have to be careful that in the future we
hear all those voice it's not discussed
but the Green Party is well and and
other parties yeah but you seem to be
saying jokes Winston's suffered and of
course she was excluded from those two
head-to-head leadership debate she
seemed to be suggesting she suffered
from lack of exposure yet the polling
did tell us and it may be harsh to say
but it's what the polls told us that the
more people saw of Joe Swinson bet less
they liked her I don't I don't accept
that what you're seeing is a campaign
that went on with you know yes we were
squeezed but I really don't think you
can you can place that under she ran a
very good a very strong campaign that
interview she did with and with Andrew
Neil it was excellent
a lot of people like that so you know no
politician is ever going to please all
the people all the time and you know I
think we need to look further at this
once we have all the details we can
examine the results in detail but I mean
I don't have you spoken to about tonight
Joe Swinson tonight or not in eastern
Barton sure but again the exit poll
saying she could be in trouble they're
there for the leadership question would
presumably be answered if she doesn't
win that seat well the the poll in
Scotland is very surprising and it's
it's not what any of the parties have
been seeing on the ground so either
we've got it completely wrong or there
is something wrong in in the exit poll
and I think it's too soon general which
what we can see is that there are a lot
of marginals
and the the exit pool doesn't pick that
up Scotland's got I think a higher
proportion of marginals in the rest of
the country and the last time it didn't
pick up that North East Fife was going
to be as close as it was I mean two
votes for all they were in it so I think
I know I'm sounding like slightly broken
Reagan to you but we do have to wait
until we we certainly do the last quick
question to her and I still have to
you'll accept I have to just go more or
less on the exit poll yes we're hearing
from homes they use of from the SNP
saying that if they do get 55 seats
where he was almost saying well that's
almost an irresistible argument to be
made to Westminster about having a
second independence referendum would you
if it was on that scale they the victory
for the Scottish National Party would
you see it that way no I am afraid I
I am a Scot and British and I I don't
see our future anywhere else but in the
United Kingdom and I will work to keep
us there and I don't accept that's the
the National enjoy Scotland's interest
okay is in going through another
constitutional bitter divisive
constitutional debate I've had eight and
a half years of it Scotland we've had
enough okay Christine Jardine thank you
very much a deed I'm adding you to my
growing list now of people from the
parties that perhaps they haven't done
as well as they might have expected in
these predictions from the exit poll my
my list of people we need to speak to
when the results are finally in hard and
fast and Edie calm is here now and we've
been looking at the results we do have
and in particular the performance of the
Labour Party in some of those seats that
have been rock solid in the past a few
of them stayed that way but Bligh Valley
and I'll show you in a second - yeah let
me let me do it straight away just show
you what that actually means for
Labour's defense actually because we
have this chart basically showing you
each of the seats that Labour is
defending so remember that these seats
the most pretty much all grey at the
moment these are the seats labour of
defending and at the start of the
night's all of these were red okay so
these are labour seats and it would take
up to a four percent swing for the
Conservatives or indeed other parties to
when these seats so reading East Croydon
central would take up to six percent
stoke-on-trent central we're all west up
to eight percent but look at this up to
ten percent swing it would take to win
Blythe Valley we are starting the first
game for the Tories is right at the end
of the spectrum of what a lot of people
expected and this is Labour's redwood
you heard that talk about the red wall
that label was defending it wanted to
withhold the Tories particularly in
these seats here well right from the
start
they have lost one on a pretty enormous
swagger ten percent swing and what's the
story behind that we'll come back and
have a look at this we're gonna actually
kind of drill into a few of those seats
so let's drill into blind valley and
indeed some of the other seats come over
here and see some of the stories kind of
behind them so this is the change in the
share of the voting you see the Tories
up by five points four percent but look
at Labor down by 15% and brexit party up
by 8.3 and then if we have a look at
some Houghton and Sutherland South kind
of you know similar story actually
labour down 19% there in terms of the
share of the vote the Tories up by 3.2
he breaks it up by 15 point 5 percent
obviously from from us kind of start of
zero effectively and here you have
newcastle upon tyne central as well it's
a similar story labor just cratering
votes across these constituencies and
what Houghton and Sunderland South
employed finally have in common it is
the fact that they are strong brexit
supporting areas you know it is the
brexit vote which might well decide this
election we talked about it being the
brexit election and how right that might
well turn out to be have a look at this
the map of the UK with all the different
constituencies let's take these and plot
them against their brexit vote so that's
the most remain over there moving
through here to kind of
middle-of-the-road to the most leave
seats and there we have Bligh Valley so
that's there you can see they voted just
around kind of 60% to leave the EU and
what we are potentially going to see if
the exit poll is right is around this
area which is Labour's red wall we're
about to see a lot of these seats
potentially turning blue if the exit
poll is to be believed so we're going to
be plotting
all of these results against all of this
now in the past it might have taken some
days for people to work out this kind of
analysis showing you about how the map
is changing what kind of divisions we're
seeing in this country we're gonna try
and do a few tonight over the course of
the next few hours so stay tuned as we
get more of these numbers through ok I
want to continue on that theme that has
been describing to us John Bercow and
just how many of those seats on the far
right of his his map
go blue I mean just looking at the exit
poll and taking the maths and a good
performance for the SNP in Scotland he
presumably up on that count would have
to take a lot of conservative seats they
also predicted to lose a few in London
in the southeast well if they're picking
up that number they're coming from
labour in the heartland aren't they yes
I mean it certainly looks like several
dozen labour held seats are going to be
lost in the North including the
northeastern the northwest and the
Midlands and as you rightly say just
computing the statistics shows that the
Conservatives must have lost at least
eight seats in Scotland now if overall
they're nevertheless having a majority
of 86 that translates into huge gains at
Labour's expense in labour heartlands
okay and Beth I mean you looked at the
body language I'm sure you watch
particularly Barry garden from Labour
you know he did he did and look I mean
fascinating details well I should say
Ronnie Campbell was the outgoing Labour
MP in Blyth Valley
he was much loved who's of brexit a he
told people to go out and vote Tory
because he wanted to to quote the prime
minister get brexit done but if you
actually drill down into that exit poll
and you extrapolate out my goodness we
could see some big upsets it looks like
Nora pitcock in Durham Durham Northwest
leadership yeah she her she looks
potentially under threat you've got such
field Tony Blair's former seat could go
Bishop Auckland Darlington stops and
South it could be closing ones but
that's Ian Lavery Lavery seat too close
to calling we're a rest that's Margaret
Greenwood seat I just want to put it
into the context of this could be a big
clear out of the Labor Party and a big
restructuring of the electro
map of our country